Kept you waiting, huh?
Welcome to Metal Gear Solid 2's Substance Sound!
Yippee!
Hello!
Welcome back, Master!
Lady!
If it isn't Saucy Mint!
Oh my god, that actually works the most here.
Hold on, I'm going to turn it up because I love this game a little too much.
That girl always keeps you waiting.
Oh my gosh, let's watch the intro real quick!
PS2?
Yes!
On my PS2, actually.
Yes, yes, yes.
Oh my gosh, a Hideo Kojima game.
The saga continues.
This intro is so awesome.
Oh my gosh.
It's so cool.
Oh my gosh, Declaration of Independence.
Wait, is that the Constitution or is that the Decl...
Um...
David Hayden!
Hold on, I'm going to turn it up a little more.
Da-da-da!
Da-da-da-da-da!
Oh yeah, Olga!
Oh my gosh, she's so sexy!
Da-da-da-da!
Oh my gosh, I can't wait to play as Snake the whole game!
Shut it for hell.
Yeah!
Why would Cam Clark be in this game?
We killed Liquid!
That's craziness!
Yes!
Yeah!
That's my president!
I love that guy!
You didn't kill Liquid.
Fox died.
Oh, true.
You're right.
Wow, look at these soldiers.
Oh, oh, oh.
Harry, Gregson, Williams!
Williams!
George Sears, my president!
Yeah!
We're still livin'!
Whoa!
I voted for that guy.
Whoa, science!
Math!
Yajishiko!
Oh gosh, I'm too excited.
Oh no, I'm too excited!
Yeah, Snake!
What?
Who that guy?
Oh, oh, Snake!
Oh, who that guy?
Who, who that?
Who's that?
What a pretty lady.
Ta-da!
Oh my gosh!
Hold on, I'll put it at that.
She's kinda cute, huh?
Yeah, she's got nice hair.
Andragos, thank you for the 20 gifted!
Ronin, welcome back!
Sir9, welcome back!
Brendan, welcome back!
Hello Mint, hello!
Hello, hello, hello.
Oh my gosh.
First of all, remember when we did this?
On April 30th?
Yo, you remember what day it is tomorrow?
It's shreddin' time.
No, unfortunately...
Unfortunately, we are not playing during April.
But that's okay.
That's okay.
It's fine.
Hold on, I'm gonna turn up the volume just a little bit.
I might be adjusting it throughout the game.
Apologize.
But yeah!
Welcome to Metal Gear Solid 2.
Which is...
I've gone back and forth so many times.
On if I really like...
On if 3 or 2 is my favorite.
And even sometimes 4.
But truly, I think 2 is my favorite.
Out of all the Metal Gear games.
I think...
I think 2 is my favorite out of all of them.
I think I, like, think about 2 the most.
I quote 2 the most.
Like, it's just...
I used to be a hardcore, like, 3 is my favorite.
That's why even I got the patchy slot.
But...
I say I look at it longingly.
I love you, patchy slot machine.
I love you.
I have a confession.
I didn't actually watch most of your members...
Members stream live yesterday.
I only hopped onto Super Chat when people suggested I should.
Because it'd be funny.
Oh, good!
Wait, you don't know what was going on then, right?
Perfect.
2 is my favorite story, but 5 is my favorite gameplay.
I think that is most people, right?
Because 5 is, like, the best gameplay, right?
Save often multiple times in the same area.
No reason.
He went back afterwards?
No!
I think Peace Walker is my favorite.
Peace Walker is so...
I love Peace Walker 2!
Peace Walker, I think, is so underrated.
It's so underrated.
I know 2 is, like, a fan favorite, for sure.
And it... I...
But I believe it's justified.
Everything about this game is, like, perfect.
Everything about this game is perfect.
Everything about this series is perfect.
I love this series.
Too bad Peace Walker co-op is dead?
What are you talking about?
Until we play together, baby!
You can always play with Minto!
What about Rose?
She's perfect?
Yes!
Oh my gosh!
If you have never played Metal Gear Solid 2 or watched anyone play Metal Gear Solid 2, get ready for the soap opera, the drama of your life...
Oh!
Oh, it's so good!
Oh my god, I eat it up!
Oh my god!
It's...
The drama!
The tea!
It's so good!
Oh my god, it's so awesome.
My favorite toxic relationship ever.
I love them so much.
I love...
I just...
Like, I can gush about everything in this...
In...
In MGS2.
I can gush about everything in Metal Gear Solid, but I can just...
Did I watch the VOD with a big grin?
Well, stop!
This is sarcasm, right?
What are you talking about?
No!
I'm being 100...
I'm always serious.
I like the part when Solid Snake has to steal the Declaration of Independence.
I know.
Where do you think they got that movie from?
Nicolas Cage is supposed to...
Is Solid Snake.
Watch Minto play MGS2?
Do it yourself!
I can...
But I can just gush about everything in this...
In this...
In this game in particular.
I think it's like the perfect balance of serious...
And goofy...
And...
Like...
Mind...
Everyth...
Spending?
Yeah.
It's just...
Too good!
Oh!
It's so good.
This game is so good.
I love it.
Mind blowing!
Yes!
Are you Richard Ames?
You must be Ames.
I love it.
It's so great.
So...
It's just...
It's just so good.
I can't get over it.
I'm so excited to be playing it again.
It's also a game that I like...
Pretty much fumble my way through.
I'm not very good at this game.
So...
I'm prepared for comments of...
Being like...
Gosh...
Minto is not very good at this game.
But that's...
It doesn't matter.
I have heart.
I love this game so much.
So...
It doesn't matter.
Wait!
Why VTuber?
Why do you love game but you bad at it?
MGS2 is the one I'm worst at too.
I think it like...
Because going from MGS1 to this game...
It introduces...
It introduces probably an overwhelming amount of mechanics that are not in MGS1.
But...
In like a good way.
It's just...
I wish I could have played this as a kid.
Because I would have been like...
Actually you know what?
I don't think as a kid I would have appreciated how...
How...
Uhh...
Advanced this game was.
You know?
I think I wouldn't...
I think I wouldn't under...
I think I wouldn't appreciate it.
I appreciated it as a kid.
Did you really?
Did you say wow this is doing feats and technical advancements?
Okay.
Okay, but I did feel that way about like Kingdom Hearts cutscenes.
I was like, wow, Kingdom Hearts cutscenes look amazing.
They look like the best ever.
Try to remember the basics of CQC.
No!
There's no CQC here!
I don't think Raiden VR's... VR mission CQC, does he?
If you're not good, a tip.
Get the thermal goggles.
Little kid got me filtered by vamp.
Too scary.
Really?
I didn't really care for this game as a kid, because it was so different.
It definitely aged good though.
That's the thing about this game, is it aged perfectly.
It can still be played now, and be such a good game.
CQC was censored by the patrons!
I never played this game until much later.
But I remember watching a friend play it the first few days.
When it was new, and this game has always been unbeatably cool.
I know!
Make sure to bring garlic.
Happy 37th anniversary to Metal Gear Vito!
Yeah!
Cool, you're doing a playthrough on PS2.
We got a re-releases, but it's nice to check out the OG platform.
Yeah, so I am playing this on my PS2.
I'm looking at my baby over there.
And, um...
Yeah, so...
Someone who played MGS1 is a young'un.
I couldn't even keep up with the characters' names.
I'm trying to think.
Yeah, like, I don't think...
I mean, I kept up with Kingdom Hearts.
So I probably could have done the same for this.
Why is there skateboarding?
Why isn't there skateboarding?
Why wouldn't there be skateboarding?
Do you have a slim?
I have a slim.
Slim, slim...
Skinny Legend.
Story became more and more relevant as the years went on.
Have fun.
Thank you!
I was so excited!
Happy birthday!
Congratulations!
With salutations!
Happy birthday!
May your sky stay blue!
Happy birthday to you!
Okay, I don't want to take up too much time.
Because I can literally just talk about this game right now.
Forever.
So we're going to...
New game!
And I have it in the pinned comment.
But I will say just in case again.
Please, no spoilers in the chat.
I will do my best as well.
I will do my best.
But please no spoilers as much as you can in the chat.
I know we all get very excited.
But just for anybody who is following along in the series.
For the first time.
We just spoiled a lot though.
No we didn't.
And...
Not a ton.
Rap kills Dumbledore.
Yeah, so...
Just do your best, you know?
I sometimes...
You know, I'm not perfect either.
I'm pretty perfect.
But I'm not perfect.
But you know.
Hmm.
Tanker plant.
What if I just skip the tanker?
Wouldn't that be...
Wouldn't that be horrible?
Wouldn't that...
What if...
Who is skipping the tanker?
I get it.
You just want to get into the game.
But it just makes me so sad.
Do my best.
Thanks for the five.
I have to thank you.
Do it.
No!
It's messed up.
Speedrunners?
No.
A true speedrunner...
Would play the whole game.
Okay.
Where do you guys think it's going to start?
I have five bucks on the Hudson River.
We're going to play on normal.
And radar type two.
Put radar off.
Am I a psycho?
Radar in Sons of Liberty will not appear at all.
This story is fictional, everybody.
Okay?
Any similarities to me?
No.
Or just similarities?
The Hudson River.
Two years ago.
You guys all owe me five dollars.
He had classified intelligence that a new type of metal gear was scheduled for transport.
The whole thing stank.
But our noses have been out in the cold too long.
How did you know?
I love you, Minto Platonic, of course.
Sighs.
I love
you, Minto Platonic.
Oh my gosh!
Thank you guys for holding your side of the agreement.
I appreciate it.
Okay.
That's enough.
Thank you.
Thank you, everybody.
Lolilule low tax.
How's the audio?
You win.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Meow.
Who's that?
I'm not.
No.
I recognize that gray-blue.
We have to give five dollars?
That's good.
Just checking if Streamlabs notifications are enabled.
Yes, they are!
Thank you!
Five bucks.
A bed is a bed.
Thank you.
Thank you for your first ever super chat.
Oh, oh, he's running.
Oh, he's running.
Wow.
He's taking off.
Oh my god.
Um, he's...
Oh, it's kind of loud.
He's got super powers.
Oh my god, who is that?
This is my actually least favorite part of the game because I'll show... I'll tell you in a second.
How did this hero... Glyph, no!
Thank you.
Whoa!
Whoa, are you okay there?
Oh my god, he's like flipping them.
You all right?
Oh, oh, be careful.
Be careful.
Harry, Gregson, Williams.
I'm a twin IRL?
You are?
That's my least favorite part of the game because now we don't have the stealth camouflage anymore.
Otacon, why is your technology so faulty?
Oh my god, it was Solid Snake the whole time!
It was a night on schedule.
Um.
No, soon enough.
Oh my gosh, it's also loud.
Spinning his little gun as usual.
Hideo Kojima.
Yaaaaaaah.
So cinematic, so awesome, so iconic.
Yaaaaaa!
This is Snake.
Kiss.
Sounds quiet.
Okay.
He accepted the thing!
Why would you call her a nanny?
How is it now?
Is it better?
Ocelot.
Ah!
Could be.
Could be!
Amphibious!
Nuh.
Not in a million years!
Agh!
Okay, we can do that.
Okay.
ASAP.
Yeah.
Mm -hmm.
Oh, yeah.
Don't worry.
Philanthropy!
I love Snake.
He's so silly.
Let's look at your gear.
Your weapon is a tranquilizer gun converted from a Beretta M92F.
Yippee!
M9.
It's a little hard to work with because you have to reload after each shot since the slide locks.
Better than scavenging at the mission site.
Look how happy and engaging you make MGS3s.
The chemical stun will take effect in a few seconds and last for hours.
Thank you.
You can take down an elephant with that thing.
Check out the laser sighting, too.
First person shooting!
Yeah!
I like that they show that you can blow out the light.
As for the equipment...
Hey, Snake?
Yeah?
Cigarettes?
What's wrong with you?
It's kind of a lucky charm.
I gotta eat them.
You haven't read the Surgeon General's warning, have you?
The rain's sound is so loud.
Here's the digital camera.
It works almost the same way as your old one.
Oh, shoot.
I never picked up the camera before.
Like, I didn't pick it up last time I played.
Yummy cigarettes!
I just need a little snack.
Oh, no.
A snack?
It's like my calorie, mate.
I'm gonna take out that guy.
You don't look armed.
Hey, Earth to Snake.
These are nice, upstanding Marines, not terrorists.
Oh, I'm not gonna take out these guys.
You're in stealth mode here.
Sure.
And if it comes to that, a little beauty sleep never hurt anyone.
Or a little eternal sleep.
By the way, Otacon, are you sure of this intelligence?
Absolutely.
Hacked it out of the Pentagon's classified files myself.
No traces?
Oh, please.
I'm too good for that.
Otacon, speak up.
I can't hear you.
I can't hear you over the rain.
Remember, there's a price on our heads.
You're just being paranoid.
I hope so.
Those men.
You wouldn't think they were anything but civilians for fear.
I went to eternal sleep.
It's not that bad.
With all the ships passing on the river and in the harbor, putting uniformed Marines on the deck would be a bad idea.
Wow.
People can get a clear view of the water from the riverside, too.
Who's getting a clear view at this time of night?
This type of weather?
According to the navigational plans, this ship should have discharged its cargo upriver.
It's all in my kitchen.
It's in there.
No doubt about it.
The military trains you to watch out for.
Also, how huge is this thing?
To have a metal gear on it?
You worry too much.
Where's the target?
Satellite surveillance is a major international pastime these days.
Maybe see it?
No.
Do you see the entrance to the holds?
Yes.
Looks like there are a few entryways into the crew quarters.
Okay.
Oh, no.
No!
My upstanding Marines!
Citizen!
No!
Not the upstanding Marines!
Looks like we're not the only ones after metal gear tonight.
Is that a chopper I just heard?
Affirmative.
Probably another cavalry.
Now I can kill them.
It's their game.
Hijack?
They're probably targeting the ship's controls.
Autocon.
How many men do you need to take over a tanker of this size?
The ship is run by a computer, so I'd say about 18 people.
That's a lot of people.
That sounds so small.
That sounds so not enough people for a ship this size.
They're next.
They look weak.
Snappable.
I managed to smuggle this map with so much stuff.
Dang, Snake.
You're so judgy.
Just because his hair isn't long and luscious like your mullet.
Oh, it's the hat.
I'm sorry.
Let's get an ID on him ASAP.
I'm on it.
Maybe you should have been like the hat, not the hair.
Why does Snake look so sussy?
The slow turn around is so funny.
Looks like the tanker's theirs now.
Oh, they just took it.
K-60 Kasatka.
Kasatka?
Kamov chopper, right?
Killer whale.
Coffee?
No.
We need to get a fix on who they are.
But I'm drinking coffee right now.
Not necessarily.
It could be the Ka-62.
The civil model.
Look, Snake.
All we need is the photographic evidence of Metal Gear.
As long as we have those, we can put it online and blow the whole thing wide open.
So no pyrotechnics, okay?
All right.
I'll do my best.
What?
This isn't like Shadow Moses.
I see.
Reach me if anything happens.
The frequency's 141.12.
What?
How can I check in and save my progress?
I'll do it.
There's a frequency set aside for it.
How can I save my progress?
140.96.
Sorry, but no Mei Ling this time.
Oh, yeah.
Call me on the codec when you want to save.
Right.
Got it.
I'll be waiting just past the Verrazano Bridge.
I'll get right on it.
You need to be off that ship by then.
I'll be in touch.
Oh.
It's me.
I'm playing now.
It's me, everybody.
Welcome.
Let's see.
We got our camera.
We got our AP sensor.
We got our cigarettes, our snack.
Let's see.
We got...
Oh, yeah.
Our M9.
Minto Gaming.
Let's see.
Let's call Otacon.
Push the action button near a scalable railing to hang off the other side.
Oh, yeah.
This is called hanging.
You can use it to move around, hide, and even maneuver around an enemy's back.
You can move left and right while hanging by moving the left analog stick or using the L2 and R2 buttons.
It's called hanging.
When you're ready to pull yourself up, just push the action button again.
A grip gauge appears below the life gauge during hanging.
The grip gauge indicates how tightly you're holding on and steadily decreases as long as you're in hanging mode.
Thank you.
Thanks for the brave.
We just started Metal Gear.
When the grip gauge goes to zero, you won't be able to hold on anymore.
We just started.
Welcome out there.
You need to hoist yourself up before you fall off.
Push the crawl button.
While hanging, to jump down straight below.
If the ground is too far below, you'll lose some life.
In some places, you won't make it at all.
Be careful of that.
Yippie yippie yippie.
Murphy, thanks for the gifted.
Let's save real quick too.
Now we just see our Otaku Dine in Montreal.
Thank you.
See you there.
Raymac, thanks for the five gifted.
I tested it earlier.
It's the same.
So if you see this file, it was just me starting up the game and making sure everything worked.
So I'll just save right over it.
There we go.
Ducky.
Thanks for the gifted.
Snake, you of course know the saying, one for all, all for one.
Yeah.
What is this all of a sudden?
Yippie yippie yippie yippie.
Oh, I figured you need a lot of motivation.
So I came prepared.
It's from the three musketeers.
The book, not the candy bar.
Anyway, it means that if you go up against everyone by yourself, they'll gang up on you.
I think.
Since you're on your own on that ship, you need to take this to heart and avoid confrontations.
How is that?
Just like the old days, huh?
He's so cute.
Almost reminds me of Mei Ling.
But you sure you got it right?
Of course.
What's with this guy?
And I'll teach you a lot more of these.
You can count on it.
Great.
Snake!
How could you say that about Otakars?
Nexy, thank you for the 10 gifted.
Cooper, thanks for the five.
Thank you so much.
You guys.
Thank you.
What's with this guy?
Thank you for the 15 gifted.
Thank you so much.
What's with this guy?
All right.
Let's see.
How do I...
Press square button to aim.
Released with fire.
All right.
So we're going to test that out with the lights here.
And then I go into this mode.
That's right.
All right.
It's going to come back to me eventually.
Where are the lights?
Oh.
I can take this one out.
Wait.
How do I...
Where's the light coming from?
There we go.
And...
Oh.
One here too.
Thank you for the gifted.
Wait.
Is there a guy here?
Oh.
Our sleepy friend?
Okay.
Let's see.
All right.
This game terrifies me.
I'll be honest.
It's so...
Like I said earlier, the lev...
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
I should probably be looking at my radar.
The level difference from the first game to the second game just like jumps immensely, I believe.
And so it kind of frightens me.
Oh.
I'm getting a little bit...
Just a little bit.
Where did he go anyway?
Grip level two for Otacon boyfriend praise?
Wait.
Actually?
How do I...
Uh.
There we go.
Grip level one.
Oh, wait.
La, la, la, la, la.
La, la, la.
A snake has such good grip.
Unlike...
Unlike a certain other...
How do I do the pull-up?
Oh, you need to do pull-ups.
How do I do it?
That's how you do it!
That was a pull-down.
No!
All the lights are back on!
And this bozo is awake again.
OK, OK.
There we go.
OK.
How do you do it?
That was a dive.
Oh, L2, R2.
Wow!
It's going down so fast!
I'm working out!
Hey, look at him.
He's just showing off at this point.
Everybody, do pull-ups together.
Getting his reps in.
A hundred!
No way!
OK.
We can do this.
You can drop down and catch to another ledge.
Oh, but then I have to go up there, you know?
It's OK.
We're probably at like 50.
We're probably at like 60 now.
We're probably...
70...
71...
72...
73...
74...
I actually have no idea what we're at.
Come on, Sig!
Your stamina!
Your stamina, man!
I like how this...
doesn't even, like, do anything.
Because we're gonna be, you know...
later on.
This will mean nothing to us.
Totally somewhere around 100.
Armless!
Yeah, later on we'll be armless.
So sad.
One hundred!
S1!
Next to the 10 gifted!
Anyway, this is a Zatsu now.
We're just yapping about...
anything...
um...
Oh my god!
That was close.
What is this super chat?
Sick gains?
Ring fit stream?
Oh!
You okay, Snake?
You alright?
Did I make it to level 2?
Is that what that meant?
Nope.
Anybody keep the gap?
I have been.
Nine...
One hundred.
I did half a pull-up.
Let's go.
Let's go!
You guys, Cole is beating everybody here.
How many pull-ups have you guys done?
Snake has done 2,000 at this point.
One focuses on the main path.
Subsequent runs are for the goofy things like this.
Yeah!
We're gonna get peed on!
Wait, is Snake losing health?
No.
Snake, don't lose health.
Zero.
We're gonna get peed on.
We're gonna...
We're gonna meet...
bisexual people.
I mean, we've already met two.
Um...
We're gonna...
What else happens in this game?
We're gonna experience the dud.
Lots of things are gonna happen.
Oh my god.
Please!
How many more?
You are at 60 now.
Wait, actually?
I will turn on DVR just so someone can count.
67...
80...
81...
82...
83...
Oh my god.
You get fat in this game.
We laugh and we get fat.
It's kind of awesome.
It's so funny.
You know?
Every time I laugh, I get a little fatter.
I think I'm in trouble.
I don't know if some of these are counting.
What am I at?
Oh my goodness!
I'm overweight because of you.
You should have a stomach.
Stop laughing.
Stop.
Most probably didn't count?
No way!
Don't say that.
This counts.
I think it counts if it goes faster.
It should count if the...
I'm done with this.
Sorry.
I'm sorry.
90 already, I think?
Okay.
I'm trusting you, Shiki.
We're going to do 10 more.
1... 2... 3... 4... 5!
You're so close, boss.
If laughing makes you fat, our wisps lean because we cry so much.
You need more.
You need to intake so much more salt because you cry so much.
1... 2... 3...
I think you just hit 90?
They were off by 10?
Oh my god.
Okay, 10 more.
1... 2... 3... 4...
5!
1... 2... 3... 4... 5!
10 more.
If not, read this message again.
Oh.
I give up.
Where is that guy?
Oh.
That was weird.
Okay, I have to press down.
Good night!
Good night, sweet prince.
Good night.
Yeah, we don't need a level 2 anyway, I guess.
I'll try it somewhere else.
One thing I do want to improve upon in this, if I can, is...
um... holding people up, shooting radios, stuff of the like.
Is that a guy there?
And then there's this guy over here, right?
Where is he at, anyway?
He's not gonna see me.
He's gonna go, nothing.
Make a pause.
Expred, are you okay?
Are you okay, buddy?
Thank you for the super chat.
Most gamblers give up before reaching.
Oh, he doesn't even come over here!
Can I get him?
Oh, shoot.
Oh.
He didn't even...
Idiot.
Didn't even notice.
What if I get him again?
Am I even shooting his body?
I can't even tell.
Maybe I'm hitting the wall.
I can't tell.
Oh!
Good night!
Oh, um...
Uh, okay.
Oh, here we go.
La la la la la la!
I'm gonna throw him overboard.
How do I do that?
Scourge, thanks for the gift tin!
How do I throw him overboard?
He's not giving me anything good.
Oh, there...
Okay, now he definitely deserves to go overboard.
Oh, the gate!
That's right.
This way!
This way, buddy!
You're going into the box!
The box!
You're going to the box!
There you go!
Good night!
Is there anything over here?
Just so good!
Thank you for the box!
I won't scatter your sorrow to the heartless...
You know, just...
You know...
Just, uh...
My bad.
I'm not... I'm not scattering your...
I won't... I won't do... I...
I won't do it.
I won't... I won't do it.
This guy show up over here?
Maybe not.
Oh, he's asleep!
Let's, um...
Take it...
Uh...
Well, he's got three still, but...
We'll just give him a little extra boost.
What do you have for me, mister?
If you have nothing, then you're going to the gate.
You've got...
Uh...
Good night!
To the gate, to the gate, to the gate...
Have mercy!
I lied.
I'm a vengeful ghost.
Wait, where's the staircase?
Over here.
I think.
Yeah.
His poor head.
Fine,
I'm committing murder.
To the gate, to the gate...
You're going to the gate...
To the gate...
Have a safe trip...
See you next fall...
To the ocean you go...
Okay.
Otacon, what were you saying?
What was so important?
Oh.
Snake, go through that door into the ship's interior.
Okay.
Push the action button down in front of the door and wait until the door opens before letting go.
If you need to open the door faster, hit the action button repeatedly...
while you turn the handle.
Got it.
Make sure you keep doing it until the door is open.
Okay.
Thanks, Otacon.
Actually, what if I...
One...
Two...
Three...
Four...
Five...
Six...
Okay.
Push-ups?
No.
Pull-ups!
One...
Now we can fall down.
Three...
Look at the butt.
The ashes.
They are ashes.
What's going on?
Come on, Snake.
How's your day been, Minto?
It's been alright.
I woke up kind of late.
But I woke up...
Matara and I were supposed to record for the podcast.
So we were going to record the Patreon episode.
And she was like...
We were going to record at 11 a.m.
EST.
She...
We ended up not recording until 1.
Because she fell back to sleep.
So, yeah.
Rip Mata.
Rest in pieces.
I don't...
Are we ever going to get grip level two?
I don't believe this is real.
I'm going in.
Next pull-up for sure.
I remember there's a guy that, like, goes down here, right?
Man.
Hey.
Does he come through here?
Actually, I don't remember.
Oh wait.
Oh no, he just kind of...
I can go in here.
Jackpot!
This reminds me of when we first met.
I was the one inside the locker that time.
We're equal now, huh?
Not unless I wet my pants.
That's a low blow, Snake.
That's a long blow, Snake.
Push the action button once more to get out of the locker.
You can see out from the slit in the door.
Make sure you check the area using first person view before you go out.
If you
open the locker, you can use the door to open it.
The door is a cover during an exchange of gunfire.
But of course, this is a pretty flimsy door.
There are limits to how many bullets it can withstand.
Don't count on it too much, okay?
That was a kiss?
Oh.
Why is...
Otacon, come on, say the thing.
Go take a photo.
Push the action button...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's right, it's gotta be a photo.
Oh.
Whoa.
Um...
Wait.
Why won't it let me open up my menu?
Do I have to...
Wait.
She's so cute.
There we go.
Maybe it'll let me now?
Unless I do it here.
Oh, yeah, baby.
Wait, how do I take it?
Uh, oh.
Square, okay.
What do you think, Otacon?
What do you think you're doing, Snake?
You don't have enough to keep you busy?
Try to remember the mission if you can.
What do you think you're doing, Snake?
You don't have enough to keep you busy?
You and your hyperactive libido.
Oh, sorry.
I can't stop staring at this girl's... Sorry, madam.
Ration!
I haven't been gifting the last two times you got gifts.
Liquid scourge?
Liquid?
Oh, oh my god.
I
don't know why they never open up for me.
Oh, oh no!
Okay, we're good.
We're still good.
Hello?
Open up.
What's inside?
Anything?
Anything of use?
That's so cool that you can like even do this, you know?
That's so fun.
Good night, sweet princess.
The last one has a poster too?
This one?
Hi!
Hey yeah.
Who do you think you're doing, Snake?
You don't have enough to keep you busy.
Try to remember the mission if you can.
I'm sorry.
Her face is up here.
She does have a really beautiful face.
Wait, where's my other picture?
Oh... sorry.
I can't stop taking them, my bad.
I over-wrote it?
I did?
No... Here, we'll... We'll overwrite this one.
Sorry, I'm still trying to get used to the commands.
Because they're different from the first.
There we go.
Still too close?
Why am I too close?
Step back?
I'm getting the goods!
What are you talking about?
Okay, okay.
Hold on, let me shut this door.
Lovely lighting.
Good.
See those lockers?
That's a good place to hide yourself if you're in a pinch.
Push the action button near the locker to open the door.
Walk inward for a quick concealment.
Push the action button once more to get out of the locker.
You can see out from the slit in the door.
Make sure you check the area using first person view before you go out.
You can also hide enemies you've knocked out in the locker.
I love doing that!
Just open the locker, then drag the body to the locker.
Then they'll be asleep.
Let's shut this one too.
Let's get another perfect picture.
Overwrite this one.
Good.
Oh, there it is.
Yes, Snake, I know.
My photography is impeccable.
Hmm...
Scary!
Nice rule of thirds.
Thank you.
Just gonna...
I gotta learn how to hold these guys up.
You don't look very comfortable, mister.
I'll help you, I'll help you.
Come here.
Oh, yeah.
This is the best angle of the game.
Hey, give me your stuff.
To the gate?
No!
Oh, thank you.
Do not knock on the posters when you lean on them.
Wait, what do you mean?
What do you mean by that?
Come here.
You're going into the closet.
You're going into the closet!
Not with the sexy lady though, she's mine.
This one.
Sorry, you don't get a view.
Come here, come here, come here.
Come here, come here.
In you go.
Good night.
What about this one?
Wait.
The other poster.
Yeah, I'm on it.
Move your hand over the center.
Sensitive!
Take!
Oh, this goes outside.
I would have caused an alert if the guard wasn't knocked out.
No.
I like how erratic the camera angling is.
It feels like I'm really playing.
So there's that guy.
Cool.
Thank you Nexidaw for the membership.
Okay, there's the two of them.
I thought there was a guy upstairs.
Am I...
Silly?
Maybe I'm silly.
I think if I get him...
When he's over there...
He doesn't notice.
What the hell?
Stop turning!
Oh my god.
What am I gonna do with you?
I'm just gonna put him over here.
I guess.
What do you give?
What kind of snacks do you have?
Put in the sexy lady pose?
The blocker?
No!
That's my heaven!
That's my place!
Oh.
Beep beep.
To be honest, I don't quite remember where to go.
I remember...
Like I need to...
There's a bomb.
I remember...
Oh.
There's that guy's shadow right there.
I remember...
I remember where I need to go because we need to fight Olga.
Going up.
Yeah.
To Olga.
I see him there.
Is this where I'm supposed to...
I'm
afraid I'm not gonna hold this guy up.
Oh.
Otacon!
I'm scared.
Hold my hand.
Did you say that locker was your outer heaven?
Yeah.
This cave is so scary.
The enemy might spot your shadow.
So you want to be careful.
You gotta watch out.
I know.
Turns and corners are especially dangerous.
But the same holds for the enemy.
If you spot someone's shadow ahead, you can avoid unnecessary risks.
This game is so advanced.
Just walk...
Just get past the corner and hold him up.
So I just like walk up and I just go...
I just go...
Freeze.
Right?
But how do you...
I don't remember actually.
How do you run with the...
Oh.
With the gun.
I can't remember.
L1 to move an aim.
Oh.
Thank you.
What if I go up to him?
Like this.
Freeze.
Oh.
Oh shoot.
Um.
It didn't work.
Dang it.
Uh.
You have to pull the gun up.
Oh.
So I come at him and then I...
And then I go...
And then I pull it up.
Flawless.
Okay.
Again.
The commands in this one are still a little...
A little for me.
You know what I mean?
So if I...
Okay.
Hold on.
He's not gonna see me, right?
You'll get the hang of it, I believe.
Oh.
Hold on.
I'm gonna wait for him to come back.
Sorry.
I'm being a baby because I want to get used to the controls again.
Foxy is still in Pirate's Cove.
So if I do this...
Freeze.
Yeah.
And then I...
Shake for me, baby.
Shake for me.
Shake for me, little...
Yeah!
Shake for me.
Okay.
Thank you.
Good night.
Oh, we got some chop grenades.
Oh, wait.
Do I have to put the...
Do I have to open this up first?
I think so.
Hold on.
Okay.
Oh.
Oosp.
I gotta get the oosp first.
Good night.
I guess we'll never get the oosp, but that's okay.
Or we'll never...
Oh.
Oh, I did just see a rash in there.
Oh, my goodness.
Let's go this way.
Does this go up?
Yes.
Oh, wait.
What's...
This goes outside.
Ew, it's wet.
Oh, no.
We gotta go to the other side.
Just kidding.
Okay.
It's only got two.
So...
Good night.
Too late for all the dog tags.
No, I don't focus on stuff like that, you know?
I just kind of like to chill and have fun with the game.
I'm not focusing on like getting all the dog tags or anything like that.
So, getting all the dog tags is the worst.
Yeah, I don't...
Really...
Care to?
So...
One more super before I eat.
Please go to sleep.
Forgot how I got here but I'm glad I never left.
Ah, thank you.
Did I get it?
I don't think I got it, did I?
No.
It's...
How...
How did that not work?
Oh...
Oh, it's a triangle.
Sorry.
Oh.
I have a...
You know.
I don't have a...
You know...
You can just say...
It's fine.
We're sneaking past.
We're very sneaky.
More chaffs.
Yeah, I do have a chaff.
Oh!
Oh-ho-ho!
My favorite angle, baby!
The camera is asleep now.
Relatable.
I think it's up here that I'm thinking of.
Surveillance camera.
All the rations.
Oh my gosh.
Scared the heck out of me.
How many rations do I have?
I don't even know.
Oh come on, I'm scared!
Oh my god, it's puny!
Blast from the hole?
Ooh.
Otacon, I'm saving.
Yeah.
Boiled.
Yeah, burn someone else's skin off.
Yeah, we're gonna boil.
We're gonna boil the soldiers.
Also, do you love that it's January 1st, 2000?
Huh!
Even a bird on high dies a gluttonous death, as do the fish of the deeps.
The lesson is, uh, don't be greedy.
The fish that belonged to a family called the deeps died from overfeeding.
The deeps?
And so did a bird that got high on something.
Probably fermented fruit.
Okay, if you say so.
I do, Snake.
He just believes in me.
Don't take unnecessary risks just because you're greedy for more items.
Hey!
Remember the deep family's fish.
Eh.
Snake just being like, alright, buddy.
Yeah, you... yeah.
Yeah, whatever you say, man.
I love it.
It's so cute.
Did they come back in here?
I can't remember.
Remember the family fish, everybody.
Snake is just like, eh?
Okay.
This isn't where the bomb is, is it?
Oh, it is!
It is where the bomb is.
Oh my gosh!
Wait, then I can get the box in here, right?
Oh, I missed it.
Sorry, Otacon.
I'm getting a box.
I'm an orange!
I'm an orange.
Just an orange!
Maybe I can hold them up afterwards.
Okay, I'm gonna do my best.
Actually, I know I'm gonna mess it up.
I'm scared.
Sleepy time?
Sleepy time.
What is this?
Oh, nice.
Where are you anyway?
Shoot the flower?
Does it actually do anything?
Just putting you right over here.
From sleepy to like...
You ain't waking up sleepy.
Advanced EEP.
Semtex?
Not Semtex!
Oh my god, the deep fishes!
My cigarettes?
Oh.
Otacon's having me be all, you know, Otacon's having me be all, you know, healthy and such.
And does this guy come over here?
Oh my god.
What if I do...
Do I shoot here?
Ah, I can't see anything!
La la la.
La la la la la.
Give me your stuff!
Your little weenie!
I'm putting you in jail!
Oh, never mind.
I don't want to go out there.
Hey!
Give me your stuff!
Make him trigger the bomb?
I'll die too with him!
Will I not?
No alerts!
Let's go!
You will.
Word!
You just want to see me dead.
I'm already dead, though.
Amazing, you're the best!
Hee hee!
I played it pretty safe, though.
So it is the Casatka.
The Casatka!
They upgraded from the Hindie.
Can
you please...
I hope there's at least one hot lady among you.
It's raining men.
Hallelujah.
Good thing we got inside before they were spying on us.
A front E.
We're suffering severe lack of girl boss right now.
It's true.
I need a lady who's not...
God, sorry.
I can't stop looking at his butt.
I need a lady who's not gonna treat me right.
I understand.
Where you going, Autoclip?
Bye.
They look really sneaky right now.
They look like they're crouching.
What was that?
Nothing here.
Oh.
Where do I get the USP from?
Do I get it after this fight?
Don't worry, we're gonna tranq her though.
Where'd she go?
Pretty lady.
Oh no, she's hoi.
Hot even.
You can't get it before this fight.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
What if I go out this way?
Okay game, I understand.
I understand what you're puttin' down.
I don't understand what you're puttin' down.
Oh, Shellushaska!
We know that guy!
Control Room.
Communications and engine room are under control.
All entry and exit points of the tanker hold secured.
Operational.
Explosives?
Scuttled!
Yeah!
Not yet!
Ooh!
Look how he's just like, just become American, man!
Father!
Olga!
Pregnant!
Wee!
And she's like, get out of here!
Get it out of...
Or she's doing the most awkward wave you've ever seen.
Freeze!
Yeah!
Hands over your head, now!
I've seen a live dubbing of this scene before.
Toss your gun overboard, slowly.
Choo!
Freeze.
A woman.
Show your face.
You men, you're all the same.
Who are you?
Oh, guys, that was awesome!
We are nomads.
Wanderers.
I said don't move.
Americans.
But you shoot women, too.
I'm a nomad, too.
Yeah.
What else do you have there?
Take the knife and toss it.
The pits.
Not there.
It actually, I feel like it suits her.
Like, it looks good.
She just looks so good.
Hold that position.
Now, turn around.
You know what you're doing.
She's just so awesome.
She's tough.
I know.
I love that.
Whoa.
It stopped raining.
Not too shabby, is it?
New York, I mean.
How do you reload that?
I guess there's some way to.
Oh.
Ah!
And that brings our duel to its conclusion.
Scout knife with a surprise.
You're a Spetsnaz.
You're a Spetsnaz!
I think you deserve a little credit.
No one's ever dodged that shot of mine.
But no one gets lucky twice, either.
Yeah.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna get hit.
That's okay.
She didn't expect to, like, you know...
Oh.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
She didn't...
I have to remember how to do this again.
Ah, let's see.
I know that I gotta...
Oh!
I've been with a punitive mind.
Doop, doop, doop, doop, doop, doop.
I grew up on the battlefield.
Conflict and victory were my parents.
You just talked to your dad.
The unit is my life.
My family.
I don't wanna hear it.
We've shared everything.
On the bad and on the good.
I don't wanna hear it.
I can't know why.
Nothing is stopping me now.
Oh, my God.
Girlie?
Nothing else matters to me.
We, uh, both got each other?
You're
non -stopping us.
Oh.
It showed me the light.
It was just like, hey, uh, buddy.
Hey.
You might wanna, like, you know, do that.
Where are you going?
Can I get it now?
Or...
I'm actually not even sure.
Did she throw?
Olga, did you throw that?
Oh.
I need you to be honest with me, okay?
Can I get her from there?
Oh.
I got her, too, somehow.
Oh,
that was close.
Oh.
It's okay.
I can get it, too.
Uh.
Can I actually?
Where do I get it from?
Yeah.
You thought.
You thought you could.
You thought you were so slick.
Hey, Olga.
You thought.
You thought you were so slick.
Did she come over here?
Can I even reach her?
Ah.
Now you're just showing off.
You're literally just showing off.
Okay.
You're all back on this side?
I got her.
Get the shot.
Do a flip.
Where is she?
She'll pop up.
Oh.
There she is.
Oh, my God.
Where
did she go?
Oh.
She's over there.
We're being rude.
We'll just hold on to this for now.
Good aim, Minto.
Minto.
Stop being sarcastic.
I don't need your sass.
Please.
This is a mess.
Lay down, Snake.
Take a breather, buddy.
That was my fault.
My timing was completely off.
It's okay.
My timing was just off.
Completely.
Don't do it.
Something pull me once.
You zigged when you should have zagged.
I know.
Distracted by armpits.
It's true.
Walkie, walkie, walkie, walkie.
Walkie, walkie, walkie, walkie, walkie, walkie.
That sure was a fight.
Your child will be fine.
Probably.
Oh god!
We killed her!
I thought this was...
Don't eat too many tranquilizers.
Tranquilizers, you guys.
We got a nice...
Her child.
Her child is not fine.
Her child is fine.
Cypher.
It looks like R2-D2.
And like a little floaty.
Cypher?
Yeah.
It looks like...
Gerlukovich!
Yeah!
I believe so.
You could say that.
I saw a surveillance remote just now.
It looked like the Cypher.
A Marine Cypher-T?
Army.
First the Marines.
Then the Russians.
Now the Army?
You're right.
This isn't gonna be simple.
Snake.
There's something I have to tell you.
Otacon?
We didn't dig up this info about the new Metal Gear on our own.
Why are you keeping secrets from me?
It was a tip.
An anonymous tip.
Anonymous?
You've never trusted those.
Why would you start now?
I am?
Step-bro?
EE!
Why would you- Such a bad nickname.
It's easier to say Emma than EE.
When was the last time you saw her?
Over ten years ago.
You think it's a trap to lure us out here?
I don't know.
After I got the tip, I did break into the Pentagon system to get confirmation.
Watch your back, Snake.
Maybe I screwed up.
I've got a light-equipped USP.
I can take them on now.
There's no ammo, but it takes a 9mm, just like the Marine's M9.
I'll find those somewhere around here.
Don't raise too much racket with that thing.
I hear you.
Hee hee hee hee hee.
I won't kill... yet.
Actually, I love having a tranquilizer.
Truly, I think it makes things so much easier.
What do you got for me?
Can I get her a dog tag?
Oh!
Yay!
I wish I could take this, but I'm just too good at the game.
Take a picture of her?
Say, tease!
Did he just kiss the...
This guy... his libido... his vibrato... his everything.
Snake... David... Snake.
Solid David Snake.
What is up with... what is... what is wrong with you?
I like going to the very tippy top.
What a thrill.
It's the wrong game, but I'm singing it anyway.
I gotta go to the bathroom, you guys.
Is it okay if I go to the bathroom real quick?
I'm just gonna chill up here.
I'll be right back.
You guys can have some rain ASMR.
Will I go to the bathroom?
Three...
Four...
I'm back!
Sorry!
I got myself a little snack, too.
A little... did you enjoy the ASMR?
Did you enjoy that?
All that ASMR goodness?
Okaeri itanaima!
No, I'm supposed to say okaeri to you.
I'm the maid.
And well...
Okoroko.
I always... I never learn in my lesson, you guys.
I always say...
Don't drink coffee.
Because it makes me too...
How do I get off of here?
And it makes me too shaky.
It makes me too hungry.
But I'm like, I gotta stay awake for these streams.
The rain honks you, honks you.
I do it every time.
Isn't there a guy over here?
Or am I crazy?
Oh my god, I can't even see the sight.
I got it anyway.
The picture of Olga looks like she's like...
Because it's so pixelated, it looks like she's dead.
It just looks like she's dead.
Isn't caffeine bad for your lovely voice though?
I don't know.
I think... probably.
But I don't drink that much coffee.
I only drink it when I'm like...
I didn't sleep well last night, so...
She isn't?
Oh, there he is.
I was like, I know some guy comes out here.
I'll kill you with this.
I'm shooting too slow.
I'm too slow.
Getting his steps in.
Some more bullets.
All the bullets that I wasted trying to get this guy.
This keeps looking like a locker to me.
You're not just pretty good, you're really good!
Snake's tiny step is when he...
You guys see that?
He's like...
I messed it up.
It's fine.
Go!
Snake!
I have a wet box.
Oh, rolling down some stairs.
How do I... It's X, right?
Out of curiosity, are you able to do this or any other future MGS runs with Snake in a tux?
Maybe.
I would have to beat it first though, right?
Calling about Olga has Otacon and Snake mentioned Meryl.
This is the bridge.
But it's not just a place where you steer the ship.
In a modern tanker, navigational, engine control, communication and all other major operational functions are consolidated in the bridge.
The ship is autopiloted via a global positioning satellite system.
This is a precision instrument we're talking about here, so it's probably best to leave it alone.
No!
I'm gonna make a crash into a bridge.
Or something.
I don't know.
The Hudson River Bridge.
Hey, Snake.
You found a handgun.
It's a decent one.
An USP.
The USP fires real bullets.
Not the knockout rounds the M9 uses.
You know that, right?
Yeah?
The USP isn't equipped with a suppressor either.
If you fire it when their enemy's nearby, they'll probably hear it.
Keep that in mind.
Having the USP will make combat easier.
But being undetected is still the best way to go.
Okay.
My USP.
Snake, Metal Gear is in the holds below the tanker's deck.
Go down.
Down.
Okay.
Wait, if I go back outside where Olga is, will he mention her?
Just noticed the stream.
Kept you waiting, huh?
Welcome!
Is it about time to tell you that Box is slaying for something?
People said that before!
Oh, she's up here.
Oh, she's gone!
Eaten by the birds.
Sorry, Olga.
Oh, come on.
Keep going.
Oh well.
It's okay.
Nothing here.
I wanna see what my box... my new box looks like.
Wet box.
Wet and weak.
No!
My wet and weak box.
My flimsy, fragile, sad, wet box.
Whose footprints are these?
No!
I'm gonna call one more time.
We'll see what he says.
Oh wait, he told me to go down.
That's right.
This is the bridge.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh yeah, let's save.
We had more people...
Oh my god.
More people join us, so...
Time to save?
Yeah!
Wet and weak sounded like a good time.
Another Chinese proverb.
Let's go!
Those who look to the heavens prosper.
Those who defy it are no more.
Do you know this one?
The meaning here is...
Snake doesn't even respond.
That you can only survive as long as you're a part of the natural order of things.
You remember pre-wrapped jeans?
Manufacturers thought that just because people loved old, broken-in jeans, they would want to buy new jeans that looked old.
New jeans!
Gojumbo does it again!
What does jeans have to do with nature and order?
Denim should fray and rip on its own.
Naturally, right?
Some designers tried to go against that and...
No one bought them.
The earnings report from that fiscal year is enough of a proof.
Earnings?
Why does it end there?
Oh my goodness.
Did they come through here?
Oh no, now he's on that side.
Okay.
But we still got our little...
Oh,
what if I usp him?
Nah.
I forgot.
Can I shoot through the box in this one?
No.
I guess it's too OP.
So sad.
Flawed recessive jeans.
Alright, to go downstairs...
Just
gonna put you over here.
Mister.
Right there.
You got anything for me?
Oh yeah, I guess I could shoot the...
the thing to turn it off...
What's it called?
Will they hear me though?
Don't remember.
That part, right?
I'm scared.
What if he hears me?
I'm too scared.
Alright, let's go.
Oh, it's this room.
Forgot about this one.
Yeah!
Fuck me!
Isn't there stuff like, underneath the table?
Time for a snack!
I wish.
What's over there anyway?
Why is there just...
Why is it in the most random spot?
I guess for that door?
Hmm.
Excuse me.
Snake is so considerate.
Oh dang, her rations are full.
Oh yeah, we can shoot it now!
Hold on, I'm gonna grab this though.
And then...
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run...
Don't wake up now, mister.
Don't wake up now.
It's so loud.
More usps.
Wait, where's this one go?
Oh, okay.
Calm down.
Okay.
Oh gosh, when they do that, it scares the bonkers out of me.
I just wanna hide immediately.
And I hate that.
I don't have the radar in here.
Why haven't we fixed the radar, huh?
And he's gonna come all the way back.
Right?
There he goes.
Okay.
Just run, Snake.
Just run.
Oh, that's right.
We can't go this way.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, we can shoot.
Nothing.
Nothing here.
Can I hide you in here?
This will be your hidey hole.
Okay.
Thank you.
Bye-bye.
Just gonna do what I did before.
We're not gonna waste bullets.
We don't need to.
His neck.
Don't worry about it.
He'll just go to a chiropractor later.
It's fine.
Dragging his face across the metal.
He doesn't mind.
Probably.
So I run up.
And then I go.
Do I have to... I have a question.
Do I have to hold them up in first person only?
Or can I do it in... like this?
Here we go.
Ah!
I learned.
Nevermind.
Shake for me!
He's got his dog tag.
Shake!
Don't kill me.
Yippee!
Okay.
You got a lucky Ronin.
This goes up.
I don't remember.
This way?
Now I'll aim at his crotch next time.
Wait.
I don't want to shoot him though.
While the other guy is up in there too.
Shake it baby.
Cause there's the other guy in the other room.
He'll see him collapse.
You know?
Like that.
And then from here...
I'm just gonna lay down.
Um...
Wait.
Where is he?
Where's your friend?
Oh.
Just kidding.
I think I go this way, right?
Cause this is um...
It's down here I think?
Right?
Yeah?
Okay.
Give me your stuff!
Crack the glass?
Oh can you?
This game is like crazy.
There's so many different ways to be able to get around in this game.
And just play it in general.
It's just...
It's actually insane.
I thought it stopped raining.
What happened?
Oh that's right.
Alright.
Stinky guy.
Stinky.
Stinky!
Do I wanna...
Wait I can't grab a stinky rations anyway.
I don't think I can grab a stinky rations.
Wait how
do I get in through here?
Hmm?
Beep beep.
Oh
nasty!
Can I have them actually?
No I can't even eat a rations.
I'm on the wrong side.
Oh okay.
Shoot.
It's fine.
We got to see our stinky friend.
Matara gone.
Barely friend.
More foe than friend.
If anything.
Stun grenade.
Nice.
Uh oh.
Wait is this a spooky hallway?
That silhouette!
No.
No!
Oregon!
Okay.
I know.
But that...
But this...
That silhouette!
Raven?
No.
There's no way.
We saw him get eaten alive.
Snake.
That shadow.
It's him.
It's Moses.
Shadow Moses.
But Raven was, you know, out in Shadow Moses.
I know.
Maybe it's the last of his nine lives.
Or maybe his maker decided to give him another chance.
You're not serious are you?
Maybe I am.
Maybe I'm not.
We literally saw him get eaten by birds.
Snake.
Watch your step.
Okay?
There was nothing left of him.
Why did they never make this into an actual figure?
I'll explain how to use the camera.
That digital camera you have was...
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Raven Nindo win.
And yes I will shoot him.
Don't worry.
Oh my gosh.
Is this a sexy lady?
Is this a...
This is probably the sexiest lady.
Even better.
Take a picture of Snake.
It'll last longer.
Good.
Snake.
There should be a door into the holds in the northwest section of the engine room.
Head west.
This game is so unserious.
I love it.
I love this game so much.
This game is so stupid.
This game is so awesome.
I love this game.
Shoot his tiny little head.
Am I actually... I can't tell if I'm aiming at it or not.
I'm like going through it.
Deeply unserious tactical espionage action.
Exactly.
I know like I've already been two hours on the tanker.
But the tanker is just so fun.
You know.
It's so fun.
Look at him go.
Look at the shadow.
Freeze.
No.
I know everybody else is like downstairs and stuff.
There's this guy.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Let's see.
Who all can we get from up here?
Like you?
And I know there's a guy over here.
Can we see him?
Oh there he is.
Dang it.
I missed him again.
There we go.
It's my controller.
My controller.
He's trying to sabotage me.
Where is he?
No.
It's the button.
It really is.
That's why I was shaking.
Please forgive old...
Oh shit.
Old controller.
Please forgive.
You know.
Old controller things.
Can I drop from here?
Will he see me?
Oh nice.
Can he see me from here?
Oh shoot.
There we go.
Okay.
I
think that takes care of everybody.
In this room.
Pull ups?
No.
I tried.
I'm sick of pull ups.
I'm sick of being healthy.
I'm tired of health.
I'm tired of taking care of myself.
Oh I forgot there was a guy down there.
Oh my god.
What's that?
Nothing here.
You know you'd be less tired if you were more fit.
Shut up.
Just a box.
Will he see me now?
Oh shit.
I almost missed that.
I almost missed that one.
I forgot about him.
Oh yes.
This room too.
Wait can I?
What was in here?
Nothing?
Just a box.
Repair of the entrance way to the engine room on the port side is complete.
We'll return to position following patrol at the small room on the port side.
Sick.
Did he leave?
Is he gone?
Wait I hear him.
I think.
Good poster.
Hey.
Stop acting up with your hyperactive libidos everybody.
Am I good?
I can't tell.
Okay.
Oh shoot.
Wait he's outside.
Does he come in?
No.
I don't think.
I don't remember.
I don't think so.
And Otacon are you gonna call me?
There it is.
Snake there's another set of infrared sensors in place.
If you touch that the explosives will detonate and that ship will be pulverized.
Oh no.
I'm not in the mood to go sleep with the fishes.
But there are too many sensors.
Looks like I'll have to find another way.
No need to worry.
There's a way through.
Take a close look.
Do you see the thing with blinking green lights right next to the explosives?
Yes.
That's the control unit for the sensors.
Wow.
Destroy that and the sensors stop functioning.
I see.
You can't get in close enough to touch it.
So you'll have to shoot it out.
But the M9's knockout rounds won't work.
The USP you picked up should be the trick.
No they're gonna hear it.
Use that gun.
But they're gonna hear it.
I'm almost out of film you guys.
2000's camera.
Oh actually I am out of film.
What do I do?
They're gonna hear me.
Hmm.
Can't hear if they eep.
True.
Can I go through this room yet?
Oh I can.
Oh.
Wait I forgot this.
Delete circuit.
Ah.
Okay okay.
It's a shortcut.
Oh I didn't even realize.
Oh.
Okay okay.
I'm gonna save this.
I don't think.
Saving in these games are always weird because.
You really just save?
You really only save to like.
Cause if I die.
I just start back at the room.
You know.
You really only save for when you're done playing the game.
But it is also good to save.
Every now and then.
Just in case something happens.
What?
Oh.
Amazing how relevant these Chinese proverbs still are.
Once the moment's gone.
It's gone.
Except for daylight savings time of course.
I wish that part was dated.
Gotta love it.
Then again you lose an hour every spring.
So I guess the proverbs are right.
I wish that part was dated.
They thought of everything.
Did they even have daylight savings back then?
Of course not.
They knew how to save time.
We're the ones that need to be tricked into it.
The moment never returns Snake.
Let's not waste it on idle questions.
Oh my god.
Otacon!
Snake doesn't even argue with the guy.
He doesn't even argue with him man.
Oh my god.
Are you kidding me?
Are you kidding me right now?
I missed my chance Otacon.
The Chinese proverbs!
Otacon.
No!
He's going even further away.
Oh my god.
I missed my chance.
Otacon.
Otacon missed my chance coming back.
Otacon please.
He's not going to see me is he?
Oh my god.
I'm so scared.
Okay.
Sheesh.
So I shoot the green things?
Wait.
Oh the green.
Like uh...
Can you shut that please?
Thank you.
This one.
Here.
There we go.
Okay.
And...
There's more though.
I think I need to get up here though.
Don't I for one part?
There it is.
And
the camera.
The camera.
Do I zoom in again?
Zoom with O?
Okay.
Thermal goggles?
No right?
I need to...
Actually I think... let me get down.
Yeah.
I'm zo...
What did I overwrite?
No!
I overwrit the man boobs!
So sad.
Where is it?
Well maybe I can go in closer.
Green.
Green, green, green.
Green?
And is anybody seeing green around here?
Anybody?
Anybody seeing green?
Little green light?
Am I blind?
Is that it right there?
You have to crouch?
I do?
Is that?
Green bottom right.
Where?
No!
Not me!
Bottom left?
Is that it?
I wish I could scoot over a little bit more.
What if I...
Get down on the ground?
Ah!
Oh!
Why did you do the thing that I told you to do?
This is such a good tutorial.
Really just teaches you everything.
The control is the true boss fight.
Here's the scary part!
You are ordered to continue manning your post until that time.
This hallway freaks me out, man.
Ah!
A person!
Smelly!
Stinky!
This isn't the one where I fight, right?
Oh my god!
My eyes!
Oh!
I lived!
Hahaha!
Oh!
My eyes!
Good night, sweet prince.
Is this the guy that's...
Yeah.
He's jamming.
Hahaha!
Wish I could take his toons, though.
Tiki-tiki-tch!
I didn't mean to pick you up.
Sure.
I'll carry you around.
A shame to shoot him.
I have to.
Just like with this buddy.
Nothing to worry about.
Hahaha!
Nothing.
I think he's the only...
Oh!
Ah!
Another guy, right?
Come on.
Excuse me!
He's listening to in the club.
Hahaha!
Go shorty.
It's your birthday.
We're gonna party like it's your birthday.
Sippin' on Bacardi like it's your birthday.
We don't get enough that it's not your birthday.
This is where I fight.
I don't wanna fight.
I'm a pacifist now.
Okay.
Everybody, shield your eyes.
Ahhh!
Oh, gosh.
My eyes.
My eyes!
When do we fight?
I know it's scripted.
Oh!
There!
That's where we fight!
I remember these boxes!
I'll never not remember these boxes.
I'm gonna have to just uspit.
I'm gonna uspit everybody.
I think.
Save.
Oh!
I forgot.
It's okay.
Like I said, if you die, you just start back up in the same room.
No biggie.
I'll just click continue.
Do you guys prefer...
Like, you know how there's the new Figma coming out of...
Snake?
Do you prefer his uniform a little more blue or a little more grey?
Cause in this lighting it's really grey.
But outside it's really blue.
I like it bluer, I think.
But...
Oh, my God.
There's so many guys!
Grey, blue...
The chat is split.
The chat's all over again.
I see the sternache.
Alright.
The lift is also under our control.
We're on the floor deck.
About to ascend to the hold...
Sir, the marine commander has started his speech already.
We will complete the preparations before the end of the speech.
All communications to the hold have been severed.
No one is aware of our presence.
I'm aware.
Let no one turn into the hold...
Oh, gosh.
Are they gonna see me if I run out?
I'm too scared!
There is one more thing.
Yes, sir.
Columbo?
Oh, God.
I'm too scared!
Okay.
I'm gonna put on the thermal goggles, warning you guys.
Warning you now.
Oh, my God.
Snake.
Actually, I know what I'm gonna do.
Who goes there?
I have a question.
Um...
Is this one of those...
I have to defeat so many guys?
Or is this I just run past?
I can't remember.
Oh, me too.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, I
should also probably have my rash on just in case.
Oh, my God.
Aim doko.
Oh,
my God.
No snake, please.
No snake.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I have to really hold down the button.
Okay.
I gotta...
I gotta really hold down the...
the R2.
There is one more guy, isn't there?
Oh, there he is.
There is two more?
Three more!
Oh, I think I got him.
We're good.
The pressure controls can be wonky.
Yeah, I really am having to hold it down or else I'm wobbling all over the place.
Nice!
I only got hit once.
Yay!
RIP non-lethal run.
It's okay.
We weren't aiming for that anyway.
I enjoy all the killing.
I'm just like what Liquid said.
That's just me.
Okay, nobody knows I'm here.
Wait, whose shadow was that behind me?
They know I'm here.
They're just letting me on in.
Oh my god, he's locking me in!
Why did you try attacking me anyway?
I know those boots anywhere.
They were made for walking.
And those hands were made for spinning.
Shalashaska!
Why are you here?
We thought you were with the Colonel.
That's your own man!
Why would you do that?
Don't tell me you're double-crossing.
Yeah, using his one hand.
I remember cutting off the other one.
The Colonel will be joining you soon.
Comrade.
Oh my gosh, I love Cherino.
Farming XP.
Comrade.
Snake, are you in yet?
Have you made it to the hold?
How do I get the libido?
We've already passed the Verrazano bridge.
How would I get the libido codec?
I'm so sad.
What?
It's all sealed.
What are they planning?
If they get Metal Gear, we're going right off the fringe.
I love this part.
It's so funny.
Are you accusing my man Ocelot of double-crossing?
No.
Never.
They have no way of knowing that the ship's been taken over.
I'm not interested in fighting these guys.
The weapons won't do me much good here.
Can you see Metal Gear?
No.
Not yet.
Hide in a locker?
I tried.
But he never said it.
He always just said, What are you doing?
Snake, you don't have time for this.
Hmm.
Okay, Snake.
Let's go over this one more time.
Okay.
Use this camera to get photographic evidence of the Metal Gear prototype.
Lock her in mine.
Now do your thing and take pictures that speak louder than the government's plausible denials.
Good.
We need four shots.
Metal Gear from the front.
Front right and front left.
And a close-up of the Marine Corps marking.
Marking?
Marking.
There should be a Marine's insignia on the body of Metal Gear.
Yes.
Just let someone try explaining away a clear shot of that.
Right.
Oh, I see it.
On his little leggy.
All right.
There's actually one little thing.
Just spit it out.
I'm used to things going wrong.
It looks like someone's monitoring our transmission.
Photo shot.
I don't have a clue.
All they're doing is watching.
It would creep me out to listen and try to interfere with our communications.
Could it have something to do with that cipher we saw?
Yeah.
Maybe.
I've switched the encryption protocol for our burst transmission for now.
What I want to do is use a different method for sending these photos, just in case.
Okay.
Instead of using the codec?
Exactly.
There's a workstation in the southeast corner of the block where Metal Gear is housed.
We're hacking.
I've made arrangements so that you can send the pictures from the machine.
What?
Arrangements.
I hitched a ride on Link 16 at a U.S.
military's proprietary network.
Managed to get into that workstation and overwrote a part of the system software so I could remote install the little app I wrote.
Shut up, nerd.
Why bother with anything that complicated?
No, it's pretty simple, really.
Who cares?
You just have to go to the machine and push the action button.
Okay.
The app will automatically launch and download the image data from the camera.
Split the files and encrypt them individually.
Why is Snake so much faster?
The data packets can then masquerade as...
Okay, okay.
So all I have to do is push the action button in front of the computer once I have the pictures, right?
Yep.
Well, sure, if you put it that way.
And one more thing.
The Commandant's already begun his speech.
But you need to get the pictures before he's done talking.
Oh, gosh.
The time limit.
How much time do I have?
I hacked into his personal files and took a look at the text of that speech.
What?
I'd say you have seven more minutes.
I wonder if he throws in a joke or two.
A seven-minute time limit, huh?
Remember, Snake, just the photos, okay?
With these kinds of odds, I won't be making any sudden moves.
What?
But that doesn't mean we can just let Metal Gear be hijacked.
Yeah.
Okay, but first the photos.
All right, we'll deal with the rest when we get there.
Right.
Stay low.
Okay.
I forgot about the time limit, I'll be honest.
I like this part a lot, though.
It's so fun.
The initiated development of Metal Gear Ray as a countermeasure to these pirated weapons forces.
The only thing that can stand up to a Metal Gear is, of course, another Metal Gear.
La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la.
La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la.
With Ray, the hundreds if not thousands of Metal Gears La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la.
that exist in the world are a threat.
La la la!
La la la la la!
I'm trying to remember how to do this part.
Can I take that guy out?
Oh!
They don't notice, right?
Hello?
He's... he's so cool!
How does he do it?
What do I... what happens if I... wait.
How do I mess with this again?
He's so awesome.
He makes shadow puppets.
I wonder if I can get that guy too.
Emmanuel!
Thank you so much for the 20!
This guy is not nearly as cool.
Alright.
That guy kinda sucks.
Nobody noticed me.
How do I make the naked ladies go on the screen?
Ray!
Um...
We'll go through this way.
Oh, the next room.
Okay.
...interference from a major player.
But this project is vital to the Marine Corps.
The enemy is sometimes closer to home than you think, gentlemen.
There we go.
No, no, no.
Snake, please.
Lay down.
Oh, I guess we're going backwards.
Okay, there we go.
Wow, this looks so familiar, doesn't it?
Experience the horror of nuclear war.
I feel like you don't really go through vents in this game.
Except in this part.
I have a daughter.
As a soldier, I know that,
unlike the Army's wrecks, it can prove deep underwater.
Move in undetected and make its landing on any shoreline.
Okay.
Its on-board joint-punch for information airing
accuracy.
And takes them out with massive firepower.
It is the ultimate weapon.
And it is yours to guard.
I'd like you all to think about what that means.
Okay.
We made it.
The National Missile Defense Program was initiated in...
Nice.
We made it.
I only have four minutes left.
Ha ha ha ha!
The National Missile Defense Program was initiated in the end of the 20th century.
Projected to completion in 2005.
However, the NMP program conducted in the year 2000 was a complete failure.
Oh!
And the success of the 1999 trials is now considered a false happening.
Bwah!
Ladies.
There was no technological solution in sight, and the program was already attacking...
Ha ha ha ha!
Beep!
Ladies.
In the light of a military dominance spelled out by rain.
Most boring movie ever.
Oh!
Bwah!
The shifting of the balance of power will mean a new world order.
Ha ha ha ha!
The Navy and Marine Corps will play a central role in its military affairs.
Ooh la la!
I love gravure!
The current power will be reduced by the completion of...
Bwah!
Snake!
Ha ha ha!
Snake just can't help himself.
Snake!
I can't even move.
Paying attention to what matters.
I'm saving them!
Bwah!
Yeah!
Which... which do... which do we look at?
Oh!
Aw...
Bwah!
Ha ha ha ha!
What's going on?
Snake!
Ha ha ha ha!
Change it back!
Ugh...
Anyway, that was a good time.
Um...
Oh...
Let me go through here.
Oh my gosh, they scared me.
The success of the 1999 trials is now considered a chance happening.
I think I might just want to run.
There was no technological solution in sight and the...
Ah!
Oh my gosh!
I forgot that they could hear me!
Ha ha ha ha!
Oh my gosh, they scared me so much!
I forgot...
I even saw the... the... the metal on the ground.
I was just like...
Hmm...
I forgot that this is a cutscene.
Ha ha ha!
My bad!
Snake!
Respond!
I've been playing this game for 20 years and I had no idea you could do that with a projector.
I feel like every time I play this game, someone is always just like, Wait, you can do that?
Wait, you can do that?
Every time.
Snake!
The National Missile Defense Program was initiated in the end of the 20th century.
Projected to completion in 2005.
However, the NMV trial conducted in the...
Move!
The year 2000 was a complete failure.
The success of the 1999 trials has now preceded a chance happening.
Oh my god!
Hey, get back in position!
Get back in position, soldier!
What are you doing?
We have intelligence that there are anti-Metal Gear terrorists planning to target the ship.
Did they go back?
Intruder to the left!
Oh my god, I hate when they do this.
Ha ha ha!
Intruder to the right!
Oh my god.
Intruder to the left!
Yah!
At ease, okay.
Should that actually happen, I expect you to be prepared.
We cannot and will not give up Ray.
Stay on your guard at all times.
I'm on my guard.
Okay.
Push!
Move on!
Okay.
There was no technological solution in sight and the...
Ha ha ha!
Intruder to the left!
Intruder to the right!
Here it is.
You're all familiar with the Shadow Moses incident during the Caesar administration.
Snake looks so good.
The current state of the Imperial Reformation is a direct result of that event.
Metal Gear...
Intruder to the left!
Wow!
Grab your reload.
Metal Gear!
Ray is so pretty.
He he he he he he he!
Hmm...
Zom!
Ha ha ha!
There was no technological solution in sight and the program was already attracting strong...
Hold on.
I gotta send my sexy ladies to Otacon for some...
I can't believe I rode over the man boob.
So sad.
Ha ha ha!
Beep beep beep bop.
Beep beep beep beep bop.
Beep beep beep beep beep bop.
Beep beep beep beep beep beep...
Beep beep beep beep beep.
Beep beep...
Colonel.
Bop bop.
Incorrect.
Scot.
This is on me.
It's so cool.
Photo viewer!
There he is!
Yes!
Is?
Sorry, but you're gonna have to go back and shoot another set.
I'll just make a backup of this one.
Otacon, you dog!
Okay, what am I seeing now?
More of these?
Is that all you think about?
Hey, what you like is your business.
Just get those Metal Gear pictures.
I'll just make a backup of this one.
Otacon!
The next ones...
Isn't this that soldier on the deck?
Olga?
Yes.
I can't believe you took a picture of her.
All things considered.
Why not?
What's next?
You're not gonna make a backup of that one, though?
Oh!
I'm sorry.
You need to take another one.
No!
The next image is...
He doesn't like... he doesn't like...
Oh!
I don't think we can use this.
Oh, my bad picture.
The last one is...
Is it a sexy picture?
I didn't think Gurlukovich was involved, of all people.
It's Gurlukovich.
We need four images.
Okay.
One from the front right...
Front right...
Front...
Front left...
And then the Marines.
Front... front right... front left.
Get the prototype on camera.
Okay.
Disconnect.
Um...
Can I take this guy out?
Oh.
Hello?
Oh, okay.
Um...
So...
Does this count?
Yeah.
Good.
Ah!
Oh, my God.
He scared me so bad.
I just thought I would sneak behind him, you know.
Okay, I get it.
I don't need all the dramatics.
Oh, Snake, the walk of shame.
Bro, walk up so fast.
I know, right?
It's okay.
I'll get him.
Do I have to do this part again?
I think so, yeah.
I'm just gonna skip through it.
Well, if I could.
I don't know if I...
Okay, first up... Oh!
Oh!
I kept that.
Neat!
Okay.
Oh, me, me, me, me, me, me.
Don't look this way.
Okay.
That guy is on another floor.
How do I get over?
I don't remember how to get over there, to be honest.
Um, can I go behind?
Just take this guy out, too.
Uh, peace.
Uh...
Marines?
Is it on the other side?
You're not so proud that you put it all over the place?
Okay.
That's fine.
I guess.
Further back?
Yep.
Marines!
Let's go!
Good.
When do they move?
I can't remember.
What if I take them out?
That would be so funny.
I don't know.
Scary.
Oh my God.
George Sears?
I'm trying to like...
Okay.
I don't think they can see me.
Oh my God.
Where am I?
This guy.
Oh my God.
George Sears.
Okay.
I guess I need to go...
here.
What counts as...
What counts as front...
Oh my gosh.
I don't have much time left.
Is he going to start talking about his daughter?
Yippee!
Okay.
I seem to be repeating myself.
Chalk it up to old age.
Front, left and front.
Okay.
I think maybe...
Should I be a wetbox or a box?
This metal gear Rey is a prototype.
Designed to be operated by an onboard pilot.
Nobody will see me right here.
His final form...
Rey will be unmanned.
Driven by tele-existence...
What is that?
The Marines label?
Oh, I already got it.
You must be tense!
Yeah, just a little.
Just in time, baby.
Only one alert?
One on purpose.
Okay!
Is...
Bing bing!
Nice!
Wait...
Wait, I didn't overlap any of them.
Oh, wait.
Wait...
Yippee!
Yeah!
I'm on my way.
You're not gonna show them the pretty ladies?
I already did.
He made backups of them, even.
Snake, what are you doing just standing there?
That is all.
Dismissed.
Oh gosh, they're gonna notice me.
Slow clap.
Salute!
Who's making that racket?
Excellent speech, my friend.
Who the hell...
Gift of the Silver Tongue.
They say it's the mark of a good officer.
How is he clapping?
End of a liar.
Americans are too in love with the sound of their own voice to speak the truth.
He has only one hand!
Identify yourself.
I'm Shaloshaska.
I am Shaloshaska.
Also called...
Revolver.
Ocelots.
Yeah!
That guy!
I love that guy!
I know that guy!
I love him!
So quiet.
So tense.
What do you want?
This machine will be quite useful.
What are you planning to do?
Steal this thing?
I love this man like you wouldn't believe.
Steal?
No.
I'm taking it back.
Dead mom.
Snake.
Snake, keep listening.
Oh.
He's just standing there.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
Blow his head off!
Grilukavitch.
That sneaky guy.
Nobody move.
Understood.
Oh my god.
They're still filming.
What's going on?
Um.
Hello?
We're just making everybody panic.
I have a walkie-talkie.
I have a bomb.
Don't do it.
That's right.
We're gonna drown.
No one has to die needlessly.
I have a hand.
Let me give you a hand.
Oh my god!
There are the Grilukavitch soldiers.
We're almost at the target.
Get a move on.
They're working on it.
Revolver.
I have a walkie-talkie.
My ears.
Oh my god.
Please.
Could we do without the realistic sound effects here?
What do you intend to do with rain?
Sell it on the streets?
I was raised in Snezinsk.
Formerly known as Chelyabinsk 70, the nuclear research outpost.
Research outpost.
What are you talking about?
After the Cold War ended, my home was bought out by the Americans.
I didn't ask for your life story.
Is there a point to this sad story?
Not you understand.
Land, friends, dignity, all sold to the highest bidder.
The United States of America.
Even the technology that gave birth to these weapons is Russian.
Developed by us.
By us?
What do you intend to do?
Russia will rise again.
And rain is the key.
I regret to inform you that I have no intention of selling Metal Gear.
As I said, I came to take it back.
Wait.
Ocelot, you couldn't be...
You couldn't be double-crossing them, could you?
No.
You wouldn't do that.
Yes?
Oh.
Returned to the Patriots.
Hello, hello, hello.
How's that possible, Ocelot?
Surely not.
Yes.
I was never in your employ, Golukovich.
This home was bought out by the Americans.
Sorry for the spoilers.
No hard feelings, Colonel.
Mother Russia can rot for all I care.
No.
Since when, Ocelot?
When did you turn?
I'm glad you noticed, comrade.
Comrade.
I abandoned her during the Cold War.
Metal Gear only has room for one.
What's going on?
Golukovich, you and your daughter will die here.
No.
Damn you!
Can you say...
Why do you want me to say lalalalalala?
Not meant to.
Mint, can you say lalalalalala for me?
Why do you guys keep asking me to say lalalalalala?
He's too good.
Gosh, Ocelot, he's pretty good.
Imagine your final words being treacherous dog.
Treacherous dog!
Ocelot's so cool!
Look at him go!
Yeah!
He's pretty good.
I love this old man.
Show's over.
If you wish to live, I suggest you run now.
This ship is still in the lower New York harbor.
You may yet make it to shore if you swim for your life.
You blew it up at him!
I'm rocking, I'm rock...
Stormtrooper aim!
Ocelot!
Yeah, Teen Titans Robin, was that him?
Oh, oh, oh, it twitched.
His hand!
He's got it back!
No way!
It's been a while, brother.
Who are you?
You know who I am.
Like, like, like what?
Like when?
Not so young anymore.
Or a snake?
A snake!
You're drowning in time.
I know what it's like, brother.
No wonder Naomi passed you over for the fox dive program.
I don't think she did.
Out!
Get out of my mind, liquid!
Is he, like, gnawing on his arm?
He's literally, like, biting liquid.
The price of physical prodigy.
A few more years and you'll be another dead clone of the old man.
Our raw materials are vintage, brother.
Big Boss was in his late 50s when they created his copies.
Oh.
But I, I live on through this arm!
Oh my god.
Look at Liquid's arm!
This part is so whack.
I love it.
Oh no.
Olga.
Golukovich.
Well, I say oh no.
I don't care about this guy.
I care about Olga, though.
That guy, he's dead too.
This part is so...
titanic coded.
Which
one of your arms is possessed?
All of me is possessed, baby!
Oh my gosh.
I can't wait.
You guys, Ray does the cutest thing here.
Ray does the cutest thing!
Cinema.
His roar, even cuter!
Even cuter!
Ray does the cutest thing!
Oh my gosh, imagine.
Suddenly you have to fight Ray.
Oh my god, Snake.
Don't die on the tanker, please.
Snake, no!
The music.
Oh, silly guys.
He's like, hey.
Hey, stop shooting him.
I'm gonna shoot him instead.
Why don't we have any counter measures for this thing?
Look how cute he is!
His eyes are really spread apart.
Yeah!
Oh my god, don't trip!
When's he gonna do the thing?
I love Ray's noises too.
Snake, wake up, please!
You're making me nervous.
You're making me nervous, Snake.
Please, wake up.
Get up, Snake.
Oh, what a nice angle.
I think so.
So...
Oh my god, here he goes!
Yes!
Go, go, go!
Do your little sippies!
Look how cute he is!
He's sipping up!
He's taking a big ol' sip!
Yeah!
Whatcha gonna do with that sip?
Ah, you know.
Water, laser...
He's so thirsty!
I love Ray!
Snaaaake!
Oh my god, Snake, please wake up!
Snake!
The cliffhanger.
There he goes!
Little Ray!
Swimming out with his tail!
I love this part too!
Look how cute he is!
He's so awesome!
Oh, thank goodness!
Snake, you're scaring me!
Power wash simulator DLC where you play as Ray.
Hehehe.
Proceeding F-Plan, sir.
I sawed this boat in half.
Backflip!
Do a flip!
I love Ray.
Ray is so awesome!
He's so nimble.
He's so special.
He's so great!
Look at him swim!
Yes, sir!
I have photographic evidence of Snake on the scene.
The cipher was most useful.
Yes, sir!
I look forward to tomorrow morning's newsflash.
I would say the Marine Corps' plans are on indefinite hold.
Yes, sir!
Mr. President!
Oh my god.
Goodbye, tanker!
Snaaaake!
What if Snake didn't know how to swim?
Oh my gosh!
It's only been three hours!
That is so, like, for the course, I feel.
I feel like...
It's so easy to spend so much time on just the tanker.
Can't believe Ocelot was possessed by Anthony from Eternal Darkness.
What a twist!
Hahaha!
Oh man.
Hey!
We beat Metal Gear Solid 2!
Oh!
Scientists had to make thousands of calculations to create the atomic bomb and determine its effects.
Computers and atomic bombs, both products of World War II, grew up together.
Smithsonian Institute.
Quickest three hours.
I've always assumed...
Snake, do you remember the sinking of that tanker two years ago?
The arm thing is just another Ocelot triple cross.
Terrorists blow a hole in an oil tanker full of crude, barely 20 miles deep.
The tanker is possessed by liquid.
Your classic nightmare.
It didn't take long for the government to put an oil fence around the whole mess.
And then that massive offshore cleanup facility went up inside.
The big shell.
The big shell!
I hear the cleanup isn't quite over yet.
It takes time.
But in the meantime, the shell's become a landmark.
A symbol of environmental protection.
Snake sounds...
more...
Twinkie.
The team's off on Bravo.
Deploy at the big shell as scheduled.
Approximately six hours ago, the big shell was seized by an armed group.
Do we have an ID?
Former members of the Navy SEAL Special Anti-Terrorist Training Squad, Dead Cell.
Dead Cell!
It's a highly trained group.
I love Dead Cell.
I hope they yell.
I hope they yell Dead Cell!
Big shell!
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
What a freak.
Offshore decontainment facility.
Big shell!
I'm so excited.
30 billion dollars.
30 billion dollars!
What makes them think they can get that much?
Gosh, they have really upgraded from the one million dollars before.
There was a government sponsor, too, who owned the big shell that day.
Or one billion dollars, right?
A VIP from one of the major conservation groups.
And one from a Rome government.
The most important person in sense.
The most important person?
James Johnson.
Unless the demands are met, the terrorists intend to blow the big shell out of the water.
And the crew will ignite, turning the Manhattan harbor into an inferno.
Oh my god.
This is not the worst case scenario.
If the chlorides being used to decontaminate the sea water go up with the oil, toxins containing catastrophic levels of dioxins will be released.
In other words, the bay's ecosystem will be wiped out and the sea will turn into a toxic soup for centuries.
Becoming the worst environmental disaster in history.
Bad soup.
Spicy soup.
I can't unhear the voice of Chuni VTuber.
I've watched before in the past when I've played.
So let's watch this game.
Infiltrate the offshore decontamination facility.
And safeguard the president and other hostages.
And two, disarm the terrorists by any means necessary.
That VTuber must be pretty cool.
If they have a voice like Ryden's.
Hahaha.
You should know that SEAL Team 10 is also conducting a rescue operation.
Soup.
The butt is acceptable.
Is this a joint effort?
It's just not the same.
Foxhound remains a covert body.
Oh my god, there's bugs everywhere.
That is an order.
Okay.
I got this.
Stealth.
Oh my gosh, here it comes.
Yes.
This is Snake.
I'm now inside Strut A of Shell 1.
How are things?
I don't know.
Why does he talk like this?
Why does Snake have white hair?
Because, you know, he got so shocked by the tanker.
There's a brand new hole cut through the oil fence.
Brand new hole?
There's someone else besides me that wanted to get in badly.
That's not possible.
What about SEAL Team 10?
That's right.
They landed on the roof of the big shell as planned.
And by the way, Snake.
We're changing your code name for all following communication.
Okay.
What's wrong with Snake?
Just a precaution.
You are now designated Ryden.
Ryden!
You've already covered infiltration and VR training.
Huh?
I've completed 300 missions in VR.
I feel like some kind of legendary mercenary.
Okay, we'll skip that part.
Make sure nobody sees you.
Okay, Ryden.
Don't get ahead of yourself.
If you need to, contact me by codec.
The frequency is 140.85.
140.85.
When you want to use the codec, push the select button.
I feel like a legend.
Alright, Ryden.
What are you talking about?
Press the select button.
Thank you.
The codec's receiver directly stimulates the small bones of your ear.
It's Axel from Kingdom Hearts.
No one but you will be able to hear it.
Alright, I'll contact you if anything changes.
Be still my heart.
First, make your way to the upper section of the big shell.
How do I get up to the next level?
There's an elevator at the far end of that area.
Nice.
Use that.
Okay.
Sounds good.
Youre new sneaking suit uses electrofiber technology.
A byproduct of fiber optics research.
Wooo!
The texture isn't far removed from rubber, but the material protects against a wide range of toxic substances.
Look at the pan up!
Oh my gosh!
Turn around for us, girl!
He's referred to as smart skin in military R for D.
The mask is so scary!
Wooo!
Wow!
What the?
I was trained by a video game.
Colonel, there's so much pressure on my torso.
It's really snatching my waist.
It's making my waist really tiny and grabbable.
Yippee!
Everybody,
welcome to...
Welcome to Bug Smush Simulator.
Welcome to the start...
of Metal Gear Solid 2, baby!
We made it!
I recognize this from a VR stream.
I know!
We're actually here now!
We're actually here now.
So fun!
Oh, where's the entrance to the room?
Only took us four hours.
Three, thank you very much.
Oh.
Ewww.
Was there anything down here?
I can't remember.
Is there anything in the water?
Go in.
Yes?
Okay, I thought so.
Alright.
How to swim.
Oh, yes.
Thank you, Colonel.
Perfect timing.
Got your feet wet?
These are the basic controls for swimming.
Stroke the water and move forward by pushing the punch button.
Push it in rapid succession to swim faster.
I don't feel like it.
Change your heading with the left analog stick.
Up will take you up.
Down takes you lower.
Left and right to face those directions.
The O2 gauge will appear under your life gauge while you're underwater.
The gauge corresponds to the amount of air you can hold from a single deep breath.
Once the O2 gauge falls to zero, the life gauge will start to drop.
Is this the Moomoo's hangout?
Okay.
You need to be aware of that.
Punch button.
Which one was punch?
Oh, gosh.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my God.
Oh, God.
Oh, swimming.
Oh, I can't go down anymore, though.
Is there actually something down here?
Maybe it's later?
Ugh.
What MGS character do you like to collab with?
Ocelot.
It's there?
Am I blind?
I passed it?
I just missed it?
Okay.
Oh, I see it!
I see it!
I saw it!
No, I didn't.
I thought I saw it.
I'm an idiot.
I thought I saw a ration.
Um...
La la la la la.
I'm not even moving.
Raiden is moving all on his own.
I'm seeing the bubbles and I'm thinking it's something.
Where did I pass it?
Slightly up?
Oh.
Oh, I see it!
I see it!
Get it.
Right on.
Yes!
Okay.
I always forget that, um...
Or rather...
You know how, like, in some games, when you swim, up is actually down?
Down is actually up?
That's where my confusion...
Because it's not... it's not... it's proper in this one.
Up is up and down is down.
But I'm not used to it like that.
I can't believe... I tried so hard to get the hyperactive libido.
I'm so sad I didn't get it.
I tried so hard to get that voice... that codec call.
I wonder why I didn't get it.
No!
Inverted is best?
I think when you, like, play so many inverted ones...
It, um...
You know, it makes it difficult.
Oh!
What was that?
That's not me.
Why am I...
Why are you looking around so erratically?
Oh!
There's... there's people here.
The codec calls are really easy to miss in this game.
Yeah!
I really wanted to see that one, though.
It's so funny.
It lives rent-free in my brain.
I can never stop thinking about...
about Snake's hyperactive libido.
A Russian private army that was in line to work with the Shadow Moses takeover group four years ago.
What's their stake in this one?
They must have made a deal.
An arrangement with the terrorists.
They've become a band of mercenaries.
An army without a country.
Oh!
Colonel!
Are you with anybody else?
The elevator is at the extreme north end.
The extreme north!
Take the elevator to the upper section of the big shell.
The totally tubular north.
The radical north.
Hope there's nobody here.
Oh my god, I can't wait to take off this stupid mask.
Army with no nation?
Right in.
Be sneaky.
Oh!
He took him out.
Wow!
He took out that ass!
I know that ass.
Anywhere!
Colonel, there's definitely another intruder in here besides me.
Oh, and he's sexy.
Not a team.
Looks like a solo job.
One man.
We may not know who he is.
But he managed to take care of every sentry in the area.
They're all out cold.
He's crazy.
He's got some skills.
We need to get an ID.
But for now, you can take advantage of the situation and get to work.
There's a terminal in front of the elevator.
A node.
Did you say nerd?
Not nerd.
Node.
Use the node to gain access to the big shell's facilities network.
Then what?
Pull up the map of the structure.
That'll let you activate the soliton radar.
The soliton radar?
True.
That radar came in useful during VR training.
A radar system.
Oh my god.
Uses biological magnetic fields as input.
I love this game.
These estimated enemy positions are projected onto a map.
Did you say nerd?
According to reference points collected via GPS signals and field personnel reports.
I think one of my favorite parts is that is like...
We need to get to the map through the big shell's node.
Not even a localization thing.
That's just one-to-one training.
No translation.
The node unit is about three feet high.
Should be colored blue.
So it's just so stupid.
Each area has at least one.
How do I gain access?
Did you say mint?
Just push the action button in front of the node.
In front of the nerd.
I'm gonna action the nerd.
The nanomachines in your body will take care of the security clearance.
Nanomachines!
And allow you access to the node.
Complete the procedure before those sentries gain consciousness.
If they spot you, you won't be able to gain access for a while.
I don't know.
Why do I have nanomachines in my body?
You won't be able to gain access for a while.
Stay on guard.
Okay.
Got it.
Oh my god.
We get to put in our name here.
Beep boop boop bop.
Why are the nanomachines doing this?
Why?
Oh.
Zzz.
My nanomachines.
My name.
I'm a lovely lady.
My birthday.
December.
October 1st.
My blood type.
Question mark.
Because I am a ghost.
My nationality.
Ghost.
Where did I put question mark?
Ah.
We'll just be of the USA baby.
The U.S.
of A.
But...
Stop.
Zanzibar.
Boop.
Yippee!
We get all of our options here.
So fun.
Yeah.
Good work Raiden.
Thank you.
The radar should be functioning now.
Remember your VR training sessions.
Okay.
The tool is exactly the same one.
I love that you get the tutorial now.
Yippee!
Ow!
Ow.
The tutorial you get replaying MGS is infectious, Minto.
Thanks, Zachary.
Zachy.
You have strong harmonic resonance, so be careful.
The Big Shell's layout map should now be available after touching the start button.
Ah, yippee!
I've set aside proprietary frequency for saves and an analyst to work on the data, too.
Who could it be?
Jack, is everything all right?
What are you doing here?
Jack, can you hear me?
Rose, you're not supposed to be involved.
What's going on?
Jack, I'm a part of this mission.
Colonel, what the hell is going on?
Excuse me?
She'll be overseeing the data saving and support.
Why her?
The Foxhound analyst that was supposed to take part in this mission was in an accident.
Rosemary was brought in as a replacement.
An accident, you see.
And according to the files, she knows you better than anybody else.
Let's go!
But an intelligence analyst is no field officer.
Not to worry.
She has our technical staff at her disposal.
She's never been a part of a field mission.
This is insane.
This is my favorite couple!
I have my own reasons for selecting her for this mission, Sergeant.
Colonel, I fail to see...
I know your VR training performance in and out.
But sometimes that's not enough.
Yeah.
You're familiar with the Shadow Moses incident?
You know I covered it in VR.
Oh yeah, 300 missions.
If there's a crucial tactical detail that case taught us...
What's that?
It was the power of the operatives' will to survive.
Ooh.
I was trained to fight.
My personal feelings have no place in a mission.
We've learned that it doesn't work that way.
And on the field, you need all the help you can get.
I need a lady.
Jack, you're stuck with me whether you like it or not.
Rose.
Rose!
You need someone to watch your back.
But I have conditions that need to be met, Colonel.
Ooh, she's a lady with conditions.
I'll perform my duties and save that mission data.
Good.
But I'm aware that technically I'm not part of the mission control team.
Yes.
After all, I'm just a normal girl who's worried about Jack.
She's just a normal girl.
But that means, Colonel, that I am not required to follow your orders...
How self-centered.
...of my immediate duties.
Jack is not simply a field personnel for me to track.
His safety comes first to me, not the mission.
How self-centered.
And because of that, I will be monitoring and keeping a record of every communication you have with him, Colonel.
Given the circumstances, you're free to do what you see fit.
Hey, I prefer this to being kept in the dark waiting.
I'd like to make a request, if I may.
Yes?
Of course.
His handle is Ryden.
For the duration of the mission...
Could you call him that?
Yes, sir.
All right, Ryden.
Ryden.
Let me know when you're ready to turn in a save.
How long do you think that's gonna last?
The proprietary save frequency is 140.96.
How long do you think she's gonna call him Ryden for?
I just switched frequencies, Jack.
What?
Do you know what day it is tomorrow?
April 30th.
Is there something special about it?
Oh god, it's already starting.
Isn't there?
Oh no.
I can't remember.
I'm sorry.
I'm so excited.
I'll keep trying until I hear the answer.
I should have...
I'm gonna let you go now, Jack.
Take care.
I should have had a heartbeat monitor on for this game.
Maybe next time.
Oh my god.
They're gonna wake up.
Uh-oh.
Ryden, the enemy sentry is regaining consciousness.
Be careful, Jack.
Ryden.
My name is Ryden.
Find somewhere to hide until the elevator arrives.
You must stay out of sight.
Please, Rose.
My...
I can't...
You have one job.
Oh my god.
I'm under enemy fire.
Secure the perimeter.
Secure...
Oh my god.
I'm scared.
Nothing?
No one?
There's no one?
There's nothing.
It's the enemy.
Andy Dell.
No, you don't.
No way.
Already?
Please.
No additional assistance.
Bozo.
Sorry.
Um...
I don't know where he is.
Oh god.
Where is he?
Ah!
The elevator's here!
Just go, Ryden.
Just go.
Nothing here.
Anyway.
Yeah, I said that nobody can help.
So sad.
Yeah!
No problems here, everybody.
The perfect escape.
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
It's just like...
The terrors call themselves Sons of Liberty.
Sons of Liberty!
The name of their leader is Solid Snake.
Huh?
The hero of Shadow Moses?
So that's why you changed my code name.
Right.
But he can't be the Solid Snake.
Yeah.
He died two years ago on that tanker.
Snake died!
After he built Sky High.
Could he have survived?
Not just because he's alive, but because he's alive.
He ripped his pants.
Not a chance.
It's just like the opening of Metal Gear Solid 1.
Solid Snake?
It couldn't be.
That guy's not working for the... for the terrorists?
There are no sentries.
But it would only take one to spot me in this light.
You never had daylight VR training after all.
How...
What a huge oversight.
Stay extra sharp until you can find a node to log in from.
What about the commandos?
SEAL Team 10 is...
What a huge oversight.
...E and C.
And the president?
Seems to be...
He was spotted on Strut B.
Strut B.
Strut B?
300 video games and not one in daylight.
Yeah.
Shadow Moses was all at night.
The Big Shell is comprised of Shells 1 and 2.
Oh my god.
We love Big Shell.
Each unit consists of a central core and six struts surrounding it.
So the whole thing is shaped like two hexagons connected end on end.
Yeah.
Exactly.
And you're on the roof of Strut A.
Shell 1 at the moment.
So awesome.
Yeah.
We love Big Shell.
Big Shell is so pretty.
First, get to a node.
Log into the network.
The node.
Got it.
What time is it?
Okay.
I still have a little bit of time.
What's this?
Get up there.
Rhino.
Bandage.
We'll need those.
But...
Ew.
Don't poop on me.
We'll get the M9.
Don't poop on mine first.
Don't poop on me.
Don't poop on me!
Let's see how Rose is doing.
My girlfriend.
You know, I just wanted to see her face.
Also save.
Yeah.
Saving!
Nice.
I'm sorry, but I still don't have a clue.
That's okay.
What is it, Rose?
Talk to me.
He's such a freak.
How important?
Important enough.
And we'll talk about it tomorrow.
Rose, can't you give me a hint?
Yeah.
Tomorrow seems more appropriate.
That's a death flag.
I need all the help I can get so that I won't chicken out anyway.
Rose, that's a death flag.
Is that the reason you decided to be part of this mission?
Okay.
I'm gonna finish this thing by tomorrow no matter what.
No matter what.
You know I'll do everything I can.
Okay.
Rose, there's something I need you to do as an analyst.
As an analyst?
What is it?
It has to do with Solid Snake.
The leader of this takeover incident is claiming that he's Snake himself.
The legendary mercenary?
I need as much data on him as possible.
Everything they have on him after the Shadow Moses incident.
He's dead now, isn't he?
Yes.
Should be a burial record somewhere, too.
You should be able to request top-level security clearance from the Colonel.
What about you, Mint?
Do you know what they want?
I'm on it.
I'll contact you as soon as I find out something.
I don't.
I have no idea.
I'm Raiden.
I'm an idiot.
So they even have his records?
How is that possible?
Wait, did they recover it from the ship?
Snake is really dead?
According to the SEAL Team 10's communications, the President was sighted on Strut B.
Raiden, head for Strut B.
It's to the northwest of Strut A, your current location.
Cross the connecting bridge between Strut A and B.
You can get to the connecting bridge from the first floor.
I feel like I'm in elementary.
Strut B.
From A you go to B.
A, B, C.
A.
Strut A.
Strut B.
Okay.
Hold on.
I have something very important I need to do.
Whoa!
Get up, Raiden.
Look at that nasty poop.
Ew!
Hit me.
Hit me, bird.
I dare you.
Hit me.
Hit me, bird.
Poop on me.
Poop on me, bird.
Look up.
Disgusting.
Hello?
Is it Rose?
Aw.
Raiden, look at that wire fence.
You may be able to crawl through it.
Dramatic pause.
That's literally what I was doing.
Crouch down using the crawl button.
Then push the left analog stick in the direction you want to move.
That's what I was doing, Colonel.
Push the crawl button again to stand up.
You can use weapons even while crawling.
This is different from VR training, so you keep that in mind.
Yeah, you can.
Thank you for reminding me, Colonel.
Oh, whoops.
I think I was thinking of crouching and shooting.
Oh, hello?
Again?
Raiden, SEAL Team 10 is in.
Yippee!
Do we really have no line of communication with the SEALs?
I mean, wait.
They don't know a thing about us.
You know we work in the dark, and this mission is no exception.
But why?
Only a few people know about your presence here.
But why can't they know?
There's no need for concern.
This operation is under Pentagon's direct command.
They might shoot me.
And the NSDD came from the Vice President.
We could work together.
Your mission may be top secret, but it's gone through the usual channels.
Okay.
You work on the cringe.
I mean, fringe.
Oh my god, the music.
Nothing new.
Oh!
I'll go check the roof.
I'll leave the first floor to you, okay?
Okay.
Bye, Gorlukovich soldier.
Okay, show off.
Okay, Raiden.
There's the nerd.
Colonel, I've located the node, but it's under heavy surveillance.
I can't get in any closer.
You have to.
Distract them.
Try making some noise to draw their attention away.
Scary.
How?
Flatten yourself against a wall and hit the punch button.
Got it.
I'm gonna flatten myself against the wall.
Before I do that...
Anything in here?
Like a... oh.
Dang it.
Oh, I need the SOCOM first.
Oh.
Uh...
Okay.
Oh my god, scary.
What if I didn't do that?
What if I just ran?
Oh my god.
Uh, hello?
Do it!
Yes, exit.
What's this way?
Is this the way?
Punch the nerd.
We need to get to...
Oh my god.
I can already hear the ciphers.
R2-D2.
Ring.
Yes, colonel?
Watch your back.
That's a cipher.
A type of UAV.
Why is he green?
Nice.
Um, Colonel, where... do I get a gun?
Okay.
Copy that.
Oh!
Yeah.
Okay, what's going on?
Oh!
What about his package?
Ooh!
Come on home.
Oh no!
Mr. President!
Huh?
What could it be?
Uh oh.
Oh my god!
We gotta go to Strut B!
Now!
But this doesn't go to Strut B.
This goes to F.
This is F.
My bad.
On our way back.
Damn.
Oh my god!
I knew that was gonna happen.
Scared the heck out of me.
Please.
Oh my god.
What do you mean, hmm?
Um...
Get me out of here, please.
No!
Thanks for the five gifted.
Um...
Oh my god.
I could use...
I could use some help right now.
I don't even have a gun!
This damn guy noticing me.
Just gonna restart.
Kill
me.
Just kill me already.
Please!
I thought he wasn't...
Yeah, like it never even happened.
Don't even...
Don't even worry about it.
Great start, everybody.
Great start.
Don't even count it.
It doesn't even count.
It doesn't even...
Just don't even think that this happened.
Okay?
This is the gameplay I subscribed for.
Jack, do you need to save?
Yeah.
Great practice run, boss.
Thank you.
Yeah, just a practice run.
Yeah.
Saving.
Rose, are you okay?
Yes, thank you.
It really scared me at first, but I think I've gotten used to it.
I'll be behind you all the way, so don't worry.
I guess women really are strong.
Not quite.
It's not women that are strong.
It's me.
Just as long as I can count on you.
Actually, that's not true.
It still scares me to death.
But I'll be strong.
I'll try.
For you.
Good luck.
What's up with this guy?
Get a load of this, bozo.
I have my thermal.
My sensor.
Yeah, I have a chaff grenade.
Maybe I do need to go through there.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, maybe I do need to go through there.
And I don't remember.
No, no, no, sir.
No, no, I'm not making the same mistake again.
You can.
Or do I go to the other side?
Do I go to that side over there?
I can't remember.
Rose is built differently.
She is.
It is the left side, isn't it?
Yeah.
Here!
A, B!
There we go.
A, B.
It's like it's not A, F.
Strat F has the M9.
I need a weapon.
I need a weapon!
Why is everything OSP?
Then what do I do?
Hanging?
Face any waist-high railing and push the action button to clear the railing and hang over the side.
Once there, you can move sideways while keeping out of enemy sight.
Wow.
I'm giving it a try.
Don't forget the grip gauge.
It will keep decreasing during a hanging maneuver.
They're really giving him a lot of credit.
Look!
They're giving him so much credit.
They're just like, yeah, you got this.
You can hang for that long.
I believe in you.
I know you can do it.
Which side should I go?
There's the other guy on the other side.
Where'd he go?
Is this the one with downstairs?
Did he go downstairs?
Will he spot me?
If he's downstairs and I'm hanging over.
Time for level 2 grip.
Oh my god, there he is.
Yeah!
I wish I could shoot you.
I wish I could make you have a sweet, sweet nap.
A lifetime of peace and quiet.
Turn around!
Go away!
What are you just standing there for?
What are you daydreaming there?
Dummy!
That guy will turn around.
Definitely before...
Yeah, there we go.
Go, go, go, Raiden.
Go, go, go.
There we go.
To the president!
Raiden is so saucy.
I know, right?
Oh my god.
Colonel?
It's too quiet.
Raiden, the president should be somewhere in Strut B, where you are now.
Okay.
His life is in danger.
Hurry.
Right.
I think my life is in danger, Colonel.
It's quiet.
Colonel?
Colonel, it's really spooky here.
Reminds me of MGS1.
I know.
It looked like I gasped for Raiden.
Uh-oh.
It's kind of spooky here.
Those hips.
I know, man.
Grabbable.
Don't get caught.
Don't get caught, Raiden.
They're gonna do the job, these guys.
Let them handle it.
They won't get killed.
They're better than the other guys.
I can't hit him.
They're
not weak.
They won't give in.
This guy, he's the chosen one.
He's the main character.
He'll live.
Ugh.
Just shoot.
Just shoot him!
It's Morb in time.
Morbius!
Ballet.
No!
That's gross.
Oh my god.
Okay, we're really playing it up now, huh?
Okay, it's just a fountain.
My goodness.
Please.
Just fall already.
Are you sure this is Alpha?
I think you instead sent in the baby squad.
Alpha where?
Right.
Ryden, be careful.
I'm scared for you.
He's gonna come after your body.
Oh.
What's happening?
Ew, there's bugs!
Oh, sorry, those are bullets.
Never mind.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, he's twitching.
I think he's enjoying it.
Get sucked.
Oh!
What is he doing?
Oh my god, he's a vampire!
Here, he's gonna do something really freaky, I bet.
What are you?
He's gonna do something really freaky here, I bet.
Oh my god.
What a freak!
Five today.
Or rather, six.
Whoa, vamp!
He really is a vampire!
Look at that smirk.
No sferatu!
Oh my god, Ryden, please!
Get down!
Ooh!
Oh.
Get my team!
Oh!
What beautiful eyes, this soldier has.
Where is he?
Oh!
I don't know.
Probably...
Wow, this soldier even has such a nice butt.
Does everybody in this series have a nice butt!?
Oh my god!
Ooh la la.
There's smell like a barker.
Eren Yeager.
It's a barker.
It has to be one.
Yeah!
What are you waiting for?
Yeah, I know how to do the hanging the grip strength.
Don't worry.
Yes, queen.
Central unit.
You're too slow, Raiden.
You're too slow.
Vamp is so OP.
It's kind of unfair.
Hold on.
I'm not an enemy.
Calm down.
My name is...
My name is Plissken.
My name is Slim Shady.
That's what he almost said.
He was quoting the song.
My name is Slim Shady.
How did you get in?
Fast rope descent from a navy chopper.
Eww!
Wait.
We saw those bugs before.
Have I seen you before?
Stop staring at his crotch, Plissken!
Are you Foxhound?
That's right.
Foxhound was disbanded.
Where were you before Foxhound?
Delta Force?
Oh my god.
Plissken is so handsome.
I was part of the army's Force 21 trials.
Force 21?
That's about tactical IT deployment, right?
Wow!
Real people!
That was me.
Not really.
So this is your first.
That's me!
I've had extensive training.
The kind that's indistinguishable from the real thing.
Like what?
Video game.
Sneaky mission 60.
Weapons 80.
Advanced VR, huh?
Advanced?
But realistic in every way.
Uh, no, no, sir.
A virtual grunt of the digital age.
That's just great.
I play video game.
That's far more effective than live exercises.
Nah.
You don't get injured in VR, do you?
No, no, no.
Every year, a few soldiers die in field exercises.
Oh my god, VR missions!
There's pain sensation in VR and even a sense of reality and urgency.
The only difference is it isn't actually happening.
Oh my god, it's Nick!
You're getting injured!
That's the way they want you to think.
To remove you from the fear that goes with battle situations.
War is a video game.
What better way to raise the ultimate soldier?
No, I think I should hold on to that.
I don't write in VR.
So you're saying that VR training is some kind of mind control?
Oh, what a funny time for Colonel to call.
The Alpha team from Navy SEAL 10 is dead.
No, a single survivor.
The kid's wired with nanomachines.
What about the President?
Looks like they took him somewhere else.
I see.
You said there was a zombie.
A survivor from SEAL Team 10.
Whatever.
Lieutenant J.G.
Plissken.
Has he seen your face?
J.G.
Plissken.
This is a top secret mission.
No one can know that we're involved.
Whatever.
It's a little too late for that.
A little too late for that.
Take a look.
What is it?
Oh!
Oh my god.
What the hell?
A Navy Captain.
Ow!
Plissken!
You alright?
Plissken, are you okay?
Give me a few minutes.
It's my... It's my Twitter header.
Must have lost a few more pints than I thought.
I want you to know your old chocolate mint cover is a banger.
Ned, thank you!
That blood-sucking freak.
Nah.
That was vamp.
Vamp.
He's Romanian.
A wizard with knives, as you saw.
He's a wizard!
The way he moved didn't seem human.
You won't see that in VR, I guarantee.
What is he?
One of the members of Dead Cell.
Yeah!
Dead Cell.
Him?
A special forces unit created by ex-president George Sears.
The name was originally intended to reflect its anti-terrorist functions.
All my favorite people.
The unit would launch unannounced assaults on government complexes for the ultimate terrorism simulation.
They were needed to show VR and video games.
I don't know how many of our troopers like you know how to deal with the real thing.
But around the time their original leader died in prison, the unit began to unravel.
George Sears.
They were always close to the edge.
But they became more and more extreme.
Began to go after U.S.
allies, even civilians.
He has made that no fewer than a hundred people died as a result of accidents the Dead Cell arranged on their own.
They were out of control, and it all came to a head six months ago.
They fixed George.
Yeah!
The unit was devastated.
There are only three left now, and you just saw one of them.
Uh-oh.
Why would you do that?
Why would they go after the Big Shell?
How should I know?
I told you they were on the Lunatic Fringe.
What about their leader?
He says he's Solid Snake.
Oh.
Snake died two years ago.
No!
Snake!
You mean the incident that made this Big Shell necessary in the first place?
Right.
And he was the one that sank that tanker.
But he's a legend.
He's a legend?
Legends are usually bad news.
There's not a lot of difference between heroes and madmen.
Wow, Plissken.
You're saying Snake is still alive and pulled another one?
No.
You and Snake have something in common.
No, he's not involved in this one.
He's got a similar thought process.
His body was positively ID'd two years ago.
True.
Snake is definitely dead.
Solid Snake...
Snake is dead.
Solid Snake is definitely dead.
And buried.
No!
What about the other soldiers?
I saw Russian equipment, too.
Former Soviet military.
They're probably mercenaries.
The Big Shell is too much ground for just dead cell members to hold down.
Rip Snake.
You can't just leave him like that.
I know.
You're just not going to let him die.
You came in alone to boot?
Why?
What are you really doing here?
I got...
He's got to save the president.
Can't tell me, huh?
Fine with me.
I don't smoke.
Keep it anyway.
May come in handy.
Ooh!
Like a little snack.
Take this too.
Yay!
Plissken, you're so kind!
I'm sorry, I didn't know you were going to do that.
Do you have a suppressor, too?
I mean...
What?
I'm not really good at stealth games.
Sometimes it's kind of frustrating to even have that thing.
Do you have any spoiler-free tips to get good?
Pep Man?
I'm not good either.
I don't think you need to answer them.
The BC connecting bridge.
We need to get there.
Can you handle it?
I need a few more minutes.
No!
Remember my frequency.
It's 141.80.
141.80.
Got it!
I've been briefed on this plant's layout.
If you need information on the place or about Dead Cell, contact me.
Okay!
You're using nano communication, right?
Yeah, but I can patch into your frequency.
Why you look so sussy?
141.80.
Hey, what's your name?
Raiden.
Raiden?
Strange code name.
Makes up for the boring one my parents gave me.
Maybe I'll find out someday.
This gets so cool!
He's so cool!
Why does Plissken look so familiar?
You think so?
He doesn't look all that familiar to me, eh?
Maybe we're mistaking him for like another character.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
One...
141.80.
Zero.
He's asleep?
Wake up, Plissken!
He just needed a little nap.
Oh, my baby!
My baby!
Look at him wake up!
Oh, he's just so cute!
Oh, wait.
His
sleeping face.
He's so cute!
I wish I had my camera!
Oh, my god!
Can I get closer?
Good morning, Plissken.
How much longer is this guy gonna sleep?
Good morning.
I wish I were that relaxed.
What?
Plissken?
He's still sleeping.
What did he just say?
Liquid.
Did he just say Meryl?
I feel like he's...
He's asleep?
Oh my god, his little baby face.
Oh gosh, I'm obsessed.
I'm obsessed!
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Let's get out of here.
Yay!
Yeah, how does Plissken... Meryl's a common name, you guys.
It's probably like a different Meryl, you know?
It's probably like a really funny coink-a-dink, though.
You know?
It's pretty funny.
Pretty funny coink-a-dink, I'd say.
Oh, we gotta get the M9.
Didn't someone say that the M9 was on...
Was on a... oh, that's not a door.
The other... on F... the F area?
Did you hear that?
How funny.
We have one.
Gosh.
Statue of Liberty.
I love mint.
Gaze it in!
Thank you for three months.
Can you shoot him?
Yeah, but... I don't wanna lose health.
He's gonna shoot me back!
You all know this.
You just wanna watch me get my butt wiped.
It is kinda worth it, though, isn't it?
Open up.
No!
Which one is this?
Oh, BC!
Is that where we need to go?
Where did it... wait, where...
Did you hear it?
You hear it?
Hmm...
I hear... oh!
I'm gonna go back and see if I can get the M9 if it's actually on the other...
Where you guys said it was.
The... uh... F... F... FF.
I'm sure it's nothing.
Yeah!
Str... F!
Yeah, yeah.
I'm sure it's nothing.
Nothing here.
I'm sure it's...
I'm sure it's nothing.
Are those guys still here?
They have to be, right?
Okay.
Whew!
That was close.
We'll level up eventually.
I might even do it off-stream, I'm not gonna lie.
Oh, wait.
This is kinda bad, isn't it?
Uh-oh.
He's gonna turn around, and I'm not gonna have any grip left.
Wait!
Uh...
Go, go, go, Raiden!
Go, go, go!
We got this!
We got...
Presidents' package can wait.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
That camera... That security camera scared me.
It was this one, right?
Oh.
Uh... I guess so.
Mint has to do the grip exercises all over again because it's a new character.
Uh... I was beginning to say I might do it off-stream.
Um... Just... Just cause, you know.
Get exploded.
Anything down here?
I see something.
Nice shot.
Thank you!
I could do it here, actually.
I could do it right here.
Everybody ready?
A one.
A two.
Three!
Four!
Five!
Six!
Seven!
Eight!
Nine!
Ten!
Eleven!
Twelve!
Thirteen!
Fourteen!
I don't know if that counted.
Fifteen!
Sixteen!
Seventeen!
Eighteen!
Nineteen!
Twenty!
Twenty-one!
We're almost a quarter of the way.
Counting with Minto.
Twenty-two!
Wait, twenty-three?
I don't know if the... Twenty-four!
Twenty-five!
I don't know if the twenty-one counted.
Twenty-six!
Twenty-seven!
Twenty-eight!
I don't know if the last ones count.
But I'm just gonna count it anyway.
Twenty-nine!
Thirty!
Thirty-one!
Thirty-two!
If you drop and quickly grab, it'll count as ten.
No way!
Really?
Okay.
Oh, drop.
Just kidding.
Oh!
Wait, how do I...
Okay, hold on.
Are you...
Are you pulling my leg?
I kind of want to test it, though.
How do you do it, though?
Oh, you need to catch onto a lower ledge.
Oh!
Okay, okay.
I was gonna say.
I don't think that's possible.
To catch it that quickly.
Needs to be ledges.
What number are we at?
Something.
Thirty-five.
Thirty-six.
Thirty-seven!
Thirty-eight!
Thirty-nine!
Forty!
Stop giving me random numbers!
We're almost halfway there.
Forty-one!
Forty-two!
Forty-three!
Forty-four!
Forty-five!
Forty-six!
Forty-seven!
Shh!
Oh!
I'm sorry.
Get up, Ryden.
It's the sound he makes.
Oh!
Come on!i Forty -eight!
I think!
Forty-nine!
Fifty!
Fifty -one!
Fifty-two!
Fifty-three!
Fifty-four!
Ryden hanging in mid-air!
Fifty-five!
Fifty-six!
Fifty-seven!
Fifty-eight.
Fifty-nine.
Sixty.
Sixty-one.
Nice.
Sixty-two.
Come on guys.
Sixty-three.
Count with me.
Sixty-four.
Sixty-five.
Sixty-six.
Sixty-seven.
Sixty-eight.
We all know what comes after sixty-eight.
What comes after sixty-eight everyone?
Sixty-nine.
Seventy-two.
Seventy-three.
Seventy-four.
Seventy-five.
Oh my gosh.
We're so close.
Seventy-six.
You guys, we're so close.
Seventy-seven.
Look at this view.
Seventy-eight.
Seventy-nine.
Eighty.
Twenty more.
Eighty-one.
Eighty-two.
Yeah, lift yourself up bad boy.
Don't stop.
You can do it.
What was I at?
Eighty-two.
Eighty-three.
Eighty-four.
Eighty-five.
Eighty-six.
Eighty-seven.
Eighty-nine.
Eighty-eight.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, wait.
I was gonna do ninety but...
Close to it.
Thanks for the pink.
Funny number achieved.
We're so close.
Ninety.
Ninety-one.
Ninety-two.
We're in the home stretch.
Ninety-three.
Ninety-four.
Ninety-five.
Ninety-six.
So close.
Four more.
Four.
Three.
Two.
One.
Yeah?
Your grip has gotten stronger.
Guess your hard work has paid off.
Yippee!
Jack, you're great.
Thank you.
Okay, I'm good.
This one's for you, Rose.
So when is the mint workout video?
Wait, which way should I go?
Up or down?
Down.
I don't even know where this leads.
Strut F Warehouse.
Oh, the warehouse!
I hate this area!
Wait, no.
I hate this area more than anything.
Nothing here.
Please don't make me go in here.
Wait a second.
Please.
I hate this area.
There it is!
We got it!
We can leave!
This is the worst strut.
I hate this room.
I hate this room more than anything in my afterlife.
Is he coming back?
Okay, I'm just gonna run for it.
We can leave.
I don't think anyone likes this room.
We'll come back to it.
We at least got what we needed.
What's on the bottom side though?
Wait.
It's still gone.
Nice.
Is there anything down here that I can get?
Let's see real quick.
There's so much loot in that strut.
I know there is.
I know.
Nothing here.
Oh my God.
Oh my God!
Yep.
Nothing here.
Okay, we'll come back.
Because it probably will be us just fumbling around.
There was already like a level 3 door.
I know I wouldn't be able to get into.
Nothing here.
Let's see.
Oh!
I just realized I might have to end soon.
Oh no, I'm not doing this again.
I think we'll call it...
in a second.
Let's get to the next area.
Because I do have a thing I need to do in an hour.
Now we can just take these guys out.
Little baby.
Goodnight.
I wish I could throw them overboard.
Should be able to.
Nothing here.
What do you got?
Anything?
What you got?
What kind of snacks you have?
Nothing?
You cheap?
Cheapo?
It's been really fun already?
I'm glad!
I love this game so much.
Oh, I wonder if Plissken is still asleep.
Do these guys have anything?
Why can't I pick up their stuff?
Pick up your gun at least.
Why?
Take it.
It's free loot.
What if I put him to sleep even more?
I think you can shoot that thing.
Sorry.
Goodnight.
It was...
It's not even...
It's a...
It's...
You know...
It's not even a...
It was a...
Always
ready.
That's my guy.
Plissken is just so cool.
Pliss...
What's going on out here?
Snake?
No, no, no.
That's Plissken.
I think you're confusing him.
He's so cool, he's like Snake.
But that's...
Oh my god.
Here it co...
Ah, I love this fire.
Fortune.
Oh my god, she's so cool.
Watch this, guys.
Watch this.
Watch this, watch this, watch this.
Nothing...
Nothing hits her.
Oh my god, the President.
We're just all shooting so willy nilly at the President.
Why in there?
Oh my god, she's so hot.
I love Fortune's theme.
Whoa!
It's all just flying around her.
Oh my god.
This is impossible!
Nothing will hit her!
Is she the one they call Fortune?
Lady Luck.
I can't believe they're just like, yeah, we're gonna shoot.
Even though the President's just lying there.
Forget Rose.
This is a lady.
Queen.
Mr. President!
Oh my god.
Here it comes.
A dud.
Uh oh.
Today is another bad day.
She's so awesome.
Is there anyone here that can give me happiness?
She's so awesome!
Me, Queen!
Me!
I can give you happiness!
Choose me!
She's so awesome.
Oh my god, she's so awesome.
Oh wow.
Wow.
Are you gonna spare him?
Brother!
Mufasa!
Help me, brother!
Long live...
No!
I'm so sorry, my beauties.
I'll see you again someday.
She's so cool.
I'll
see you again someday.
Colonel, Seal Team 10's Bravo Team was wiped out.
I see.
What happened to the cargo choppers?
Both of them are at the bottom of the harbor.
Looks like your new hosts have a Harrier, too.
A Harrier?
What is this?
Calm down.
It just means they anticipated the attack.
What?
Besides, since the Seals drew their fire, your infiltration went off without a hitch.
On top of that, we know their defensive capabilities.
Are you saying this was all a feint?
Raiden, get a hold of yourself.
The entire mission is in your hands now.
Do you understand?
No pressure.
But there's no time for questions.
A Harrier?
I hope I don't have to fight that.
You mean the hostages?
They could be in danger, yes.
But we need to consider the possibility that they'll blow the whole shell.
If that toxic spell does take place, it'll devastate not only the harbor, but poison the coastline for generations.
Oh my god!
Raiden, we've had to adjust the mission objectives.
What's that supposed to mean?
The priority is now on removing those C4s of the terrorists wired over the big shell.
I know that.
The President can wait.
The President can wait?
Colonel, you know I'm no bomb disposal expert.
That's not a problem.
The Bravo team brought an explosives pro in with them.
Oh, let's go!
He was supposed to stand by on Strut C, according to their mission plan.
What are you talking about?
You should find him there.
Is this according to Simulation 2?
Get to Strut C and find him.
Understood.
But I need to ask you something before I go.
Is this just like my video games?
Uh, shut the hell up.
They couldn't hit her no matter how hard they tried.
Is this like my video game?
Right.
It's like being in a nightmare you can't wake up from.
Jack, snap out of it.
Rose!
I can't believe you're on this mission.
I keep thinking I'll wake up.
Raiden, this is real.
And that's why you won't wake up.
But nothing seems real.
I've made up my mind to stay with you.
Whether this is real or a bad dream, I'll keep watching you till it's over.
Thank you, Rose.
And I won't let you be just a dream.
Are you two done?
Raiden, you're leaving on Strut C.
Cradle has no...
Cradle is so no-nonsense.
He's just like...
Raiden asks him something and he's just like, What the hell are you talking about, man?
He's like, shut up.
Shut the hell up.
Shut up, Raiden.
He's already done with Raiden.
He doesn't even want to deal with him.
Glad we got to see a dud.
A dud.
Colonel's too old for this, it's true.
No chill, Colonel.
Oh, I like this place.
Because that's the bathroom.
Actually, I don't remember.
Oh, that scared me.
This auto...
Oh, yeah!
Lady Liberty!
Ho ho ho ho say...
Can you see?
USA!
By the do...
Jack, is that you?
Yeah.
Don't...
They were jorking it in the bathroom.
And by it, I mean...
I mean my M9.
Jack, when you get home, let's have a homecoming party.
Just the two of us.
She just raises every...
That's a good idea.
I'll make dinner.
What's wrong?
Well, that sounds good, but how about we eat out at that one restaurant instead?
Is Rose's cooking bad?
You know, the place that we went to recently with the amazing lobster?
I really like that place.
Well, yeah, I guess that's okay too.
Nothing.
I just love lobster.
Yeah, can't wait.
Woo hoo!
Well, then I'll make a reservation.
Promise me you'll come back safely.
Maybe.
Don't worry.
Every red flag.
Every death flag ever.
Pushkin!
Pushkin, wake up!
I almost made a mistake.
Sorry.
I wish I was that relaxed.
Does this turn on?
It does.
Look at me, handsome devil.
Watch this.
Hold on.
Oh.
Uh.
Damn, I can't.
Wait, hold on.
Let me see if I can do it now.
No, I can only crouch.
I was gonna try.
Wait, maybe I could do this.
No.
Never mind.
Wash your hands.
I didn't go to the bathroom.
Rose, I'm in the girl's bathroom!
I'm smelling in here.
What can I do for you, Jack?
I'm in the girl's bathroom.
Shadowboxing?
I'm shadowboxing in the girl's bathroom!
What are you gonna do?
How do you feel about that, Rose?
How do you feel about that?
I can't believe you, Jack.
Do you know what that place is?
I just thought maybe the bomb disposal instructor might be in there.
Why would he be in there?
Well, you never know.
He's AWOL, and...
Even AWOL, a normal guy wouldn't go into a woman's bathroom.
You're the only one I know who would.
You're like really strange.
Rosemary, settle down.
It's all right.
You should probably look someplace else.
I've never heard that one before.
What's that?
Nothing.
That's that.
Return to your duties.
You guys are unbelievable.
That was even the negative reaction, too.
That was so funny.
That was the negative reaction.
Someone said press L2 and R2 while I'm...
While I'm looking at myself.
Wow.
What a stance this guy has.
You never know.
See, there's bandages.
Oh, sorry.
Pazizamine in here.
Why is there pazizamine in the bathroom?
What an idiot.
What an egotistical woman.
Oh, I can't wait to hear that line.
It's my favorite one, you guys.
I think... See, this is why I consider two my favorite.
I just am always quoting it.
I can't stop quoting this.
This stupid series.
I can't stop quoting it.
Hey, Mint.
You're like really strange.
Stop.
MGS2 has good quotes.
It really does.
The brain rooms are small.
Yippee!
Freeze!
Don't shoot.
He's our man!
I think.
Probably.
I'm not NYPD.
I came in with the Bravo team.
Who are you with?
And what happened to SEAL Team 10?
I have some bad news for you.
They're all dead.
All of them?
They threw a dud.
You don't understand.
Did I tell you you could move?
Oh my god.
Plissken, you scared me.
I thought you were napping.
Don't go pointing that thing everywhere, kid.
What's your name?
My name is Peter.
Peter Stillman!
Lecturer at Navscolio at Indian Head.
Also a consultant for the NYPD bomb squad.
A poor old man who got dragged along for this picnic.
Peter.
I thought you'd retired.
I did.
Can't keep up with everybody, as you can see.
Oh my god, Peter.
Thinking of Hunger Games now.
A famous church got wiped off the map thanks to me.
Too many lives inside.
All I lost was this leg.
His guilt.
So you're the bomb disposal guy.
Raiden, stop.
Raiden, you are...
Your sass is off the meter.
Please.
Kid, this is the bomb disposal guy.
Open any explosives disposal textbook and you'll see his name.
This guy's talking about how he's like...
Just ancient history now.
Lost his leg and all these people died and he's just like...
Why did they bring you out of retirement then?
Because the terrorist group here includes one of my students.
Raiden is serving.
Fatman!
He built an atomic bomb when he was only 10.
I created him in a sense.
And that's why you're here.
How did a 10-year-old create an atomic bomb?
Where didn't a 10-year-old get uranium from?
I wouldn't say that.
How?
Where did he get it?
There are at least two people here who can claim to be experts at bomb disposal.
He made it out of Legos.
Are you two with SEAL Team 10?
Yeah!
We're with another squad.
My name is Plissken, Lieutenant Junior Grade.
Honored to meet you, sir.
Mr. Plissken, do you have any experience with explosives disposal?
Don't worry about me.
And he looks young, but he can do it.
But we need more manpower.
I'm...
What's your name?
Raiden.
That's an odd name.
Why does everybody say that?
There was also an engineer with me.
An engineer?
A skinny guy.
He went in with us.
Not a fat man.
Skinny guy.
Where is he?
I haven't seen him since that skirmish.
Was he killed?
I don't think so.
I didn't find his body.
I see.
They told me he was a security systems architect for the Big Shell.
Why would they take a civilian along?
Everything in this structure is computer controlled.
He was supposed to get us past all the security measures.
I never heard anything about that.
He had official orders with him.
We'll leave that for later.
Who could it be?
But there's no one left from the CO's EOD squad.
Yup.
So we have to do it ourselves.
Fat man versus skinny guy.
But I've never defused a bomb before.
Hold on a sec.
Off to confer with the CO again.
Hey.
Um...
Yeah.
I'm a...
Glad to hear Stillman is safe.
I'm a dog of the governor.
Colonel, you know I've never been trained in bomb disposal.
It's all right.
The man you're working with is the best in the field.
What the heck do you think you are?
All you have to do is follow his directions.
You will, of course, keep your identity and mission objectives to yourself.
Is it true that an engineer came in with Stillman?
Why does Raiden, like, go off the screen?
I wasn't informed of that.
It's probably something the SEALs decided on their own.
Hmm.
There are more important issues at hand right now.
The enemy may retaliate for the failed assault.
What the heck do you think you are?
Get those C4s neutralized now.
Okay.
Colonel, I'm not qualified for bomb disposal.
Jack, it's me.
Rose?
You can do this.
Trust me.
You haven't had bomb disposal training per se in VR.
But you're more than capable of handling C4.
This is a little different from using C4.
You're up for this.
You know that.
How about it, kid?
Are the results in yet?
Plissken infiltrating my thoughts.
300 video games, by the way.
There's no need to think about this so much.
Yeah, you'd think that they would give him something.
You won't actually be dismantling the bomb.
That's not for amateurs.
What we'll try here instead is a temporary freezing measure.
Here, look at this.
Okay.
I'm looking.
Could you move it any slower?
This is a C4 bomb.
Please move it slower.
I'm scared.
It's live.
You can see it pulsing.
Yeah.
There we go.
Simple, huh?
The spray freezes the detonator instantly.
How long does the effect last?
There's no way the thing can detonate in this condition.
Nice.
Even if you leave it alone, it'll stay out of commission for at least 24 hours.
Okay.
That's enough time.
That is enough time.
If we had the manpower, I'd recommend complete disposal.
Instantly.
I know, right?
Instantly is a bit of a stretch.
Check the floor, ceiling, walls, under a table, everywhere.
Try to imagine the locations the bomb will choose.
That won't be easy.
We don't know a thing about Fat Man.
Is there anything that'll help us locate the bombs?
I love Fat Man.
We know one thing.
We know two things.
He's a Fat Man.
It can recognize ionized gas emitted by C4s.
Ooh, all stinky.
In other words, that little gadget sniffs out C4's scent.
That's right.
I've established a link up with your radar network.
Miss loves Fat Man?
I love Fat Man!
Have the sensor activated and keep your eye on the radar.
I really like Fat Man.
He's using some other odorless substance.
He's so awesome.
Sniffle, sniffle.
I know Fat Man well.
I know how into his own aesthetics he is.
Signatures?
Yes.
On every bomb he builds, he always leaves a trace of the cologne he uses.
Fat Man!
The sensor also picks up that particular scent spectrum.
Is that something he learned from you?
No, it was his own quirk.
He's just quirky like that.
He wouldn't work by any rules except his own.
I used to treat him like a religion.
And common sense wasn't one of his strong points.
I thought I taught him everything I knew.
I have no children of my own.
And I thought I found a son in him.
He had the right stuff, you know.
There's something very unusual about an ability like that.
Even at Indian Head he got special treatment.
Yeah, the porch is real good.
So awesome.
I remember some people called him one of the fat cats.
Maybe that's what started all this.
I didn't teach him the most important thing I had to tell him.
He's not a cat, I'm a Mario.
There are some things you have to pass on.
The trick is to know which one.
Right.
All I taught him was skills.
I don't know if you should teach anybody skills on how to make a box.
And now I have to stop him from using it to destroy us all.
I wonder if, you know...
Oh my god, watermelon.
Let's see how well that sensor works.
I want some watermelon.
I'm activating him.
Watch.
Okay.
You see the green stuff on the radar?
Whoa!
That's a visual representation of the C4 scent detected by the sensor.
It's a pretty big area, isn't it?
Don't complain.
It's better than nothing.
Just activate the sensors.
How can we not smell it?
Why don't we just use our nose?
I think Batman and Running Man would have cooperated a little bit.
I think so.
We have to keep out of the enemy's sight, too.
Because the radar gets knocked offline when we're spotted.
Batman is against Running Man.
Exactly.
Batman skates.
It's too cool.
Smell-O-Vision.
I know the structure of this facility.
And if he wants to take out the plant, where he would target?
You know this for sure?
Of course.
I taught him the techniques he uses.
His ideas are based on my theories.
No.
Demolition is a kind of ideology.
It makes no exceptions for time or place.
Your student went rogue!
Stolen!
Is that the flag?
Is that the Sons of Liberty flag?
Hmm... okay.
Where'd they put the half-pipes?
Yeah!
What are you giving me?
What is it?
Level...
One!
I like the idea of using hints to find the bombs.
It's like a game of Hot Cold Men.
Oh, I hate that room.
No...
No... I don't wanna go in there.
This is messed up!
Why can't I... why... why...
Damn.
Plissken is better.
You're right.
I don't even know why I'm trying to compare.
Hey, hey, hey.
Where do you think you're going, mister?
Yeah.
Uh, no, sir.
Ooh.
You don't have to be so honest.
Just, uh, hide in the fridge.
Why don't you just let us handle the grunt work?
You can tell us what to do over the radio like in the original mission plan.
All right.
I'll give you instructions from here.
I may also need to prepare a backup plan just in case.
In case of what?
Good luck to both of you.
This is a dangerous one.
Go out the exit from the kitchen.
You'll see a cess box.
Who dares, wins.
Oh, okay.
I'll check.
If anything comes up, let me know.
Okay.
My frequency is 140.25.
140.25.
Good luck, kid.
I'll see you later.
Hihihi.
Semper Fi.
That man's no SEAL.
I don't even think he's a Navy man.
Huh?
Oh.
He's sussy.
Semper Fi.
Marine Corps talk.
Ooh.
Semper Fi.
Why did he even think to say that?
Normally, team leaders stay in the CP and give orders with those headphones.
And as far as I know, SEALs keep their officers away from the field.
Act natural.
Semper Fi.
And who dares, wins is a model of the British Special Air Service.
Plissken walking away being like, nailed it.
Nailed it.
Is he one of the terrorists, then?
They don't suspect a thing.
Somehow, I don't think so.
If there's someone to suspect, I'd put my money on you.
Hey!
What do you mean by that?
Is it because I'm...
Is it because I'm so beautiful?
No.
Somehow, I don't think so.
I'm... riding.
Just take care of those bombs for now.
Okay.
What about you?
They could be back in this area soon.
You hide in there.
I'll hide out in this pantry for a while.
Yeah.
If I lock the door, it should be alright.
Plenty of food in here too, so you don't need to worry about me.
But a bathroom.
I'll give you instructions by Kodak from here.
Do you need to go potty first?
Yeah.
Good luck, kid.
Hi.
Oh.
Bomb disposal is a face-off with your own mortality.
Don't let the fear get to you.
When you give in to the fear, the darkness comes.
Why would it have a lock?
Because...
Well, actually, it's weird why it would have a lock on the inside.
Having a lock on the outside makes sense, because you don't want people getting into the pantry.
But why would it have one on the inside?
Hmm.
Strange.
I don't know.
Okay.
Nice.
So...
Pluskin went this way, right?
Did he go this way?
So the food doesn't get out?
Oh.
So you aren't locked in.
But then people can just unlock it from the...
Oh.
Oh!
Ah!
What is this?
Column?
Plissken!
Yeah, he told us all about this!
No way, it's part of his box?!
No way!
I'm sorry!
No, the orange!
I can't believe he's just like...
Just pocket the longest of all.
I know, he literally told us all about it.
Plissken, I just saw someone with a box!
I just saw a box!
A man in a box running away!
Yeah.
Delta?
No.
They got weird when Colonel Jackson, Fortune's husband, was sent to jail.
Sent to jail?
For what?
Corruption.
He misappropriated government funds.
Sounds like he deserved it.
That's what everybody else thought.
Except for the members of Dead Cell.
They felt the Colonel was falsely accused.
Fact is, they took the case to the powers that be.
But they never managed to reopen the case.
Was there any truth to their claim?
Who knows?
Whatever the situation is, Dead Cell's name was tainted.
And Colonel Jackson?
He was being held at Leavenworth.
Was?
Meaning he's been released?
Well, in a manner of speaking, the Colonel's dead.
Apparently, he lost the will to live and died in prison.
The members of Dead Cell snapped with the loss of their leader.
They underwent a radical change and became uncontrollable.
And that's why they undertook this terrorist operation.
Seems as good a reason as any.
Vamp is a member of Dead Cell.
Born in Romania, his specialty is knives.
But I guess you know that by now.
When he was just a kid, he lost his family to a terrorist bomb that went off in a church they were attending.
His body pierced by a crucifix, Vamp was buried under the rubble for two days before he was finally rescued.
During those two days, he survived by feeding on the blood of his family to quench his thirst.
That was how he acquired a taste for blood.
So that's why they call him Vamp.
No, Vamp isn't for vampire.
It's because he's bisexual.
Rumor has it, Vamp was the lover of Scott Dolph, the Marine Commandant who accidentally died two years ago.
Scott Dolph was also the father of Fortune, the Dead Cell leader.
Fortune's old man?
But Fortune and Vamp?
You noticed, eh?
Not bad for a rookie.
As you say, Vamp and Fortune are very close.
Not lovers, but very close.
Friends?
No, there's more to their relationship than that.
It's true.
Vamp was her father's lover.
Would it have been better if it was with her mother?
Well, I don't really think they care what you think.
Focus on the mission.
I just don't understand the correlation.
By the way, have you ever met the guy before?
I don't understand the correlation.
I don't know why he's so matter-of-factly and is just like, uh, no.
It's because he's bi.
I told you, the Dead Cell is a group of madmen.
I wouldn't take anything they say very seriously.
And are you a vampire?
Maybe.
Maybe I'm more vampire than ghost than I thought.
What do you know about that strange woman?
You mean Fortune?
She's the Dead Cell leader.
Oh, come on!
I want the box!
I think we missed the box codec.
That's so sad.
...known to her friends as Lady Luck.
Lady Luck?
Yeah.
She got the name because bullets seemed to veer away from her in battle.
People have heard her say that her fortune in battle was payback for the lousy luck she's had in life.
Lousy luck?
The death of her father, the Marine Commander.
The conviction of husband and Dead Cell leader, Colonel Jackson.
It's okay, we'll get through these.
I like listening to them anyway.
These events were followed by her mother's suicide, the loss of a husband, and the idea of a convict in the family apparently took her over the edge.
Lady Luck, but she's not very lucky.
Fortune was three months pregnant at the time, and the shock of her mother's death led to the loss of her child.
Oh my god!
Add to this her husband's death in prison a few months later and...
To sum it up, in the six months after her father's death, she lost her family and everything that mattered to her.
Jeez, she's had it rough.
Yeah.
The thing is, she didn't grieve long.
Instead, she joined the military.
Now why is that?
Revenge, baby.
Do I look psychic?
My best guess is revenge.
Yeah.
I heard that she firmly believed that her husband was framed.
Do I look psychic?
Plissken is so sassy.
Anyway, by the time she came out of basic training, she'd proven many times over that she was gifted with an unusual streak of luck.
Oh my god, sassy Plissken.
In fact, some say she sold her soul for it.
Her soul?
Her uncanny luck earned her a reputation that led to her appointment as the head of her husband's unit, Dead Cell.
Hmm...
What else do you have to say to us, Plissken?
Fat man.
Yeah!
Supposedly, he's nicknamed after an atomic bomb, but to me, he's just a fat man.
Something straight out of a sideshow.
If he even has a bit of spare time, he spends it disassembling and assembling his Glock over and over again.
What are you trying to say, Plissken?
He can't stand to have his hands still.
He's extremely vain about his hands, keeps his fingers as slender and soft as a woman's.
Wow!
They say he's always looking at his hands, giving himself manicures.
Fat man is so eccentric, I love him.
Plissken, I saw someone wearing a cardboard box just now.
A box?
I don't know anything about that.
You sure you weren't imagining things?
Of course I'm sure.
Do you think it's one of the members of Dead Cell?
How should I know?
I don't want to fight someone like that.
Why not?
Because it looks so dumb.
Anyone who's willing to be seen like that must be completely insane.
What the- I mean, he's a psycho.
There's no question about it.
Oh.
Yeah.
Plissken, what do you know about Stillman?
He's a bomb disposal expert.
Probably the best in the world.
What else?
What do you mean?
Like, why he retired.
Yeah.
Are you here to gossip?
No.
Then get back to work defusing those C4s.
Okay.
If there's something you need to know about Stillman, go ask him yourself.
What was Stillman's 140-the-25?
Are you here to gossip?
Yeah.
It appears that Fat Man placed bombs within each of the struts.
It's likely there are no bombs planted on the connecting bridges.
Now we have another thing.
Head for the struts for which you have not yet finished exploring.
I got 6-9.
6-9.
That's 6-9.
Aw.
The little piece of the box!
I'm sorry, Plissken!
I'm sorry!
I broke your box!
Oh.
Okay.
This guy is...
Oh, shit.
Um.
Oh
my God.
That was close.
That was too close.
Let's go back inside.
That was way too close.
How nice of that guard to wave through your whole codec call.
Is there anybody in here?
Can we go around?
Oh, I can go through here now, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Because I gotta go, you guys.
I've got to go.
Jack, do you need to save?
I do!
And we got all the codec stuff, so I should save that.
Yay!
Hang in there.
That's it?
That's all you gotta tell me, Rose?
That's all?
That's it?
That's all you gotta tell me?
Nothing else?
Okay.
Sure.
Before you go, did you work out the Eternal Darkness save issue?
I did!
I did, I did, I did.
Yeah.
Thank you, thank you.
Chu.
Chu!
Marilyn, thank you!
Thanks for another MGS Saturday.
Just letting you know that you have gotten so much better at being sneaky.
Really?
You think so?
Thank you!
I'm still scared for the rest of the game.
Do you remember what day it is tomorrow?
I don't know.
I'm just a silly guy.
Bomb disposal?
Diffusion?
I don't know.
I don't know what day it is tomorrow.
I don't know anything.
I'm silly.
I'm just a silly guy.
For the next time I play this, I believe I will be playing it on Thursday.
Thursday.
Because I will be busy on next Saturday.
So I'm sorry.
Because I feel bad.
The previous Metal Gear was...
When I finished Metal Gear Solid 1, it was on a weekday.
It wasn't a Saturday.
And the next one will not be a Saturday either.
In fact, I think...
I think, honestly, my next couple of Saturdays are going to be kind of busy.
So I thought...
I even considered.
I was like...
Hmm...
Maybe I should...
Maybe I shouldn't start Metal Gear until my weekends are a little less busy.
But we'll still have Metal Gear at some point.
Deja vu.
I've just been in this place before.
So...
Yeah.
But...
So next Thursday, we'll be playing more Metal Gear.
Spike!
Thank you for the 20k!
Thank you!
And...
Yeah.
So...
My weekends coming up for the next couple of weeks are like kind of insane.
Kind of crazy.
But...
If I can, maybe I can make Metal Gear Sundays.
If I can't do Saturday.
I know some Sundays I can't do Saturday.
I can't even do...
It's kind of complicated.
But...
Mint Frenchman.
Hope for good reason.
Yeah!
It's just like...
Not next weekend, but the weekend after.
I'll be guesting at a convention.
In Texas!
I'll be seeing the Did You Know Gaming videos on Metal Gear games.
They got David Hayter to voice them too.
I have seen them!
Yeah!
I have.
MGS2 is always super cool.
Super comfy somehow.
Really?
You think so?
I think it's the most stressful game in the world.
Wow.
Comfy.
Yeah.
Where in Texas?
I'm sorry.
I don't have the information.
It's called Anime Fest, I believe.
So...
But yeah.
Don't work too hard.
Thank you.
Arlington?
Is it in Arlington?
Maybe Arlington, Texas.
Yeah.
So...
Hmm.
I do have some stuff that I need to take care of for next weekend.
Actually.
That I'm taking care of soon.
Tonight.
So...
Yeah.
Excited for Anime Fest.
It's so close to my house.
Oh my god!
I'll see you there!
I hear this George Sears guy is pretty neat.
He is...
Solidus.
Welcome back.
Oh my gosh.
George Sears?
He's like the...
He's my president.
That's the best president.
I love that guy.
But yeah.
Thank you for...
For part one of...
MGS...
MGS2.
We will continue next week.
And we'll get all into the fun stuff.
It's just...
It's just all beginning.
All the cool craziness is just starting.
So...
Yeah.
Thanks for such a great streaming though.
Thank you!
Thank you guys for watching!
Thank you guys for hanging out.
And I will see you guys...
I will be streaming tomorrow.
I'll try and get a waiting room up tonight.
I'm not quite sure what I'm doing...
I think I have two streams tomorrow actually.
Well...
One for Patreon.
And one on my channel.
Patreon for the...
Podcast.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oki doki!
Otsu minto!
I'll see you guys tomorrow!
Ittarashii!
Bye bye!
Thank you!